[Music]
me
[Music]
me
my mo my me my may
there's far
corners to my bed
and foreign
that song has been stuck
in my brain
uh for ages
since that trailer dropped uh that has
been literally stuck inside my head
um hello
hi welcome uh it's been a bit i know
i've been to the hospital i know i'm
fine i know
uh but yes
we are back at it again with another
five nights at freddy's revisited this
time it is ultimate custom night as you
can see from uh
this here i have the ultimate of the
custom night
to go into this yeah i was in the
hospital again
uh it's fine
same thing as usual
intestinal blockage it happens it's just
a common thing because i've had multiple
abdominal surgeries in my life scar
tissue does build up it's a factor
thankfully for the past two times that
i've gone in i have not needed surgery
again
um and this one god
uh i i in the past like you've probably
seen the pictures of me when i'm in the
hospital um i have this tube in my nose
right uh so that is a nasogastric tube
it's called an ng tube it's common thing
in hospitals and surgeries because what
it is it's a tube that literally goes
down
through the nose
down your uh esophagus and into your
stomach and it
literally vacuums everything out it
sucks everything out of your stomach up
into the tube and then it goes into a
dump the reason is when you have an
intestinal blockage if you think of your
intestines as one long tube this has
nothing to do with ultimate custom night
but i know there's people that are
curious about this which is why i'm
going to be talking about it um because
i was in the hospital for this and
everyone's always curious uh but an ng
tube it sucks out because when you have
blockage nothing can go through your
from your mouth to your butthole it's
one long tube it's pipes right think
mario right think mario pipes that's
basically what it is the food is mario
going through the pipes and then it just
like goes through but then
uh-oh mario can't go down out the
butthole anymore this is a bad example
um
but when you have a blocks that so what
happens oh you suck it back up out um
you're eating
what it's a perfectly fine analogy it's
fine um but this time i did not need
an ng tube
because i uh
the initial
uh
blockage
the danger of blockage is that it keeps
compacting all of the food that you ate
and eventually like the threat is that
your intestines could rupture right
that's very bad um but i did not eat
enough beforehand to cause a problem it
was just coincidence i went in early
enough i noticed i know the pain uh so i
was able to get to the hospital soon
enough that i didn't need it
however
however
which is why the difference between um
my latest tweets which is so funny i've
talked about this with other youtubers a
few times now um the difference being
uh
from the last time i it was i needed to
poop this time i just needed to fart
right uh so i did and it's so funny
because i talked to all these other
youtubers about it's like man you're the
only youtuber i know that can get on
trending
just from a two-word tweet that all it
says is i farted and it has 300 000
likes and everyone in the response is
just like yay hooray
it's and i'm not proud of that but it is
a thing that i that i could say has
happened twice you know it's that that
meme like if i had a a quarter for every
time that's happened i'd have two
quarters anyway
so i'm fine
um
but the solution this time
was
and this is if you're eating i apologize
it's just i'm going to be talking about
this i will be playing ultimate
customize in just a moment and also i'll
be talking about how uh on monday in
space with markiplier part two launches
it is
i won't spoil anything about it there's
a link in the description that leads to
the premiere page i highly recommend
going checking it out because i will i
hope you all are gonna be there if you
haven't seen part one go see part one
part two is
gonna be so fun you are going to love
part two i guarantee you're gonna love
part two but link's in the description
um back to the story so
uh
how
it was solved
is
seven
rounds of hospital-grade laxatives
we had this idea uh back in the day for
unisonis we had this idea ethan had this
idea actually he had this title i hope
i'm not spoiling it um by revealing this
um maybe i am but i don't think we'd
ever actually do it uh it's an idea
called
laxative olympics right
that that's just it that's the title of
it and the idea was that you would take
a laxative and then you would try to go
as far as you can without
[ __ ] yourself
so
so basically uh that's what it was and
when when you think of like taking
laxatives right usually in any other
normal circumstance you
you take it once right so i had a sh
they gave me a shot glass worth of
hospital grade laxatives i was like okay
here we go and then um
then
two hours later they give me another
then two hours later they give me
another and another and another and
another and another
every two hours so this is i was in the
hospital the reason i'm talking about
this is because i was in the hospital i
i forget that people trickle into these
live streams and then there is context
that is lost
but i was in the hospital
so
seven rounds you do not understand
the devastation that will do to your
body
and man your shots shots shots shots
yeah absolutely anyway so i'm out of the
hospital i'm totally fine i'm 100 okay
it is all good
so many people are just like oh my god
just play the game it's my stream i went
into the hospital i get to do whatever i
want with this stream i am going to play
the game however this
is ultimate custom oh
forgot there was sound
there we go that's probably pretty good
okay so this
is ultimate
custom night ultimate custom night is a
very interesting one in the five nights
at freddy's
book the encyclopedia universe it is
uh
just
a custom night it's basically a choose
your own adventure much like in space
with markiplier part two of which is
linked in the description below hey why
don't you click on that and then set a
reminder and then join us for the
premiere where we can all watch together
live
at noon pacific on monday
i don't care watching school
skip gym class to watch it um but this
one is interesting because you get to
set each one of these individually
based on their
difficulty right so harkening back all
the way to uh five nights at freddy's
one with 420 mode which was a very
difficult mode
and
this one has
what's called 50 20 mode
which is something i have not beaten
i've been the hardest mode on almost i
think almost every one of the
the previous ones that had this kind of
mode i did not beat this one and yes
i know that has been a
a black mark on my record of
five nights at freddy's being the king
of that thing it's really hard and my my
biggest problem with it
was that
what at the time and the reason that i
did not want to dedicate so much time to
doing it is because i was busy with
other things at the same time but also
just because i didn't like the idea that
you needed to
exploit the game to be able to beat it
however
i've not looked up in depth uh into the
strategy of beating
ultimate custom knight at 50 20 mode
and i've seen
more and more people through sheer
reaction time speed and knowledge of the
game
be able to beat this with with a few
things that are are common to the quirks
of the game which i'm fine with quirks
of the game and the programming and the
layering of it is interesting and i like
that because that feels fine but i
remember when the first few people were
beating it it had to do with like
breaking the game and kind of like
waiting and finding this like rng to get
through however i believe
oh
who's uh i was on matpat's stream a
while back dj something oh i feel bad
what a handsome man
an incredible individual
unbelievable but it's just like uh i
want to show you real quick what 50 20
mode is now i'm not i don't even
remember how to play but i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you this so that you get an
understanding of what chaos 5020 mode
actually is
i forgot how many goddamn controls catch
fish oh i forgot
oh my god okay let me just i i'll
i'm gonna give this a glance and then
i'm gonna come back to it later so you
got your powdered power generator silent
ventilation heater power ac global music
box
all off
and then all off of the
or x is all off okay z is flashlight
which is strange
uh i guess it makes sense
[Music]
close forward vent close left door
monitor closed door close side bend
catch fish just the idea of catching a
fish
you have to catch a goddamn fish uh
close ad
desk fan and then return to menu which i
won't need because i'm going to be sent
to the menu real quick
so this is 50 20 mode
[Music]
dude oh my god catch the fish
i don't remember anything about hi oh
god hello jesus
oh god
oh my god what do i i've forgotten
everything
oh my god
you're not so big
hey
hey you dick
you shut up i'm perfectly average height
how dare you
anyway so that how okay what was the um
what was the volume like on that one i
made it 18 seconds i think you have to
make it what four and a half minutes
uh
it's it's it's uh it's chaos
hello can i get back
every hour on the air oh yeah every hour
oh god i don't remember
uh yeah how was the volume volume okay
on that um volume was all right i like
the sound of that volume was a-okay
which is good in my book
okay
so
now that we've established what that is
i'm going to take them all back a bit
and i'm going to just
get familiar with the office again
a little higher a little up on the
volume was great
volume good volume was fine i'm getting
a lot more volume was fine than it needs
to be turned up at all the volume was
alright so i want to go back into this
with nothing there's no animatronics now
this is 050 mode which is a perfectly
valid way to play this game uh
but the reason i'm doing this okay
there's actually buttons
where's the where's the honkable nose
and there he is
oh there he is
okay so
this is the chaos that is this
particular version of the game there are
so many mechanics you got
one two three four five six six is all
off i believe same as x uh you've got
all of these different cameras locations
you've got these things called faz coins
which are all over i needed to reset the
ventilation i forgot that was a thing
i forgot about the fast coin system
oh the nonsense that is that you have
your ventilation system with blockages
of where the vent goes you have your
duct system
of the different places where anima
animatronics can go through
because remember there are 50 of them
and on the right side here you can get
all your different uh
things to do i could still lose this by
running out of power i think but you got
your temperature that you need to worry
about ventilation that you need to worry
about
what did i hear
there shouldn't be any animatronics here
there shouldn't be any end why did i
hear something
okay whatever there's a
it was a el sweepo i don't remember
so you have this one is where toy freddy
is playing
a version of five nights at freddy's
this is where you are buying
things
to
the death i know this is called the
death coin or the dead coin or something
like that but you need to buy these
because they can show up in this hallway
there's two foxes that's right there are
two foxes
i completely forgot about that
it's two foxes
there's three
what oh yeah
what can i do for you why are you here i
don't even remember why you're here uh
soundproof sure
right he shows up no matter what now
clicking on that is a random chance of
dying instantly or getting a bonus i
don't know if the meta is to click on
him all the time and just get the rng of
the bonus because i imagine that
sound proofing is good i don't know i
have no idea i have not read up any
strategy about this the only thing i've
seen is a few people actually beat it i
don't know how they did that
i don't remember what that coin does
what does that coin do
okay we got this this this this
you gotta reset the ventilation here all
the time
you've got this side vent here which is
controlled by f
and then you have
the desk fan is controlled by space
all off
desk fan oh it starts off
who touched me bird i did could i get
ten fast coins please thank you i don't
know what the percentage of that is i
think the difficulty does go up
but i'm not 100 sure
death coin stops certain things from
killing you okay i don't know what
certain things that is just yet i'm
going to slowly introduce animatronics
here
very slowly and steadily as i go by
because
i really truly do not remember
the vast majority of what these things
do i love the double eyebrows here love
the double eyebrows i'm at 20 power
because i was looking at that
ventilation
it's just such chaos it's so it's it's
madness right and i love madness life
needs a bit of madness but this game is
madness this is just pure chaos
absolute unadulterated chaos
hi
me bird likes you so i'll do you a favor
okay thank you i'll take the i don't
know what
one one percent power one percent power
doesn't seem like a lot
but then again sound proofing probably
is the best thing to go for that i think
yeah life needs a bit of madness
absolutely
okay oh [ __ ] i'm out of power
but i think it ends at 4 30. doesn't it
it's 4 30 right
yep okay 4 30. i did it
zero points
god
okay
so i did it i won my first round of
ultimate custom night
hey look at that
that's great so these power-ups um
basically they give you a little bonus
i'm probably pretty sure that beating it
uh requires some of these or at least to
play i i think giving you the tiniest
bit of advantage i think you can't get
the act the maximum amount of points if
you do
dd repel but i don't really care about
that
i don't really care about getting uh 10
600 points
um so also in this if you don't remember
there are these various uh game modes
that they have assigned here that offer
a certain amount of difficulty right
it's basically to get you started
because some of these things who knows
where they get started um
hold on i need to really wrap my head
around this
the challenges are great because they
get you started out and you can feel
like you're accomplished but in all
honesty it's probably not that great the
hardest difficulty that i personally
beat this last time i did it was
550
i beat them all at level five difficulty
that was like my personal thing i felt
like that was where there was a nice
balance of challenge i felt good about
beating that and i felt like i was very
accomplished for that that's where all
that every hour on the hour came into
play there very good but you know it's
no
2050 mode so let me let me start off
it was chaos
old friends no
no
no no no no no no
creepy crawlies one
that's probably a lot of vent i'm gonna
start with bears attack because you got
freddy fazbear from the left hall keep
track of him on the monitor and shut the
door when he's standing in the doorway
he moves faster as the building gets
warmer
golden freddy he will appear in your
office throw your freddy mask on or pull
up your monitor quickly to cause him to
disappear phantom freddy shine your
flashlight on him to cause him to fade
away if you don't he will jump scare you
giving time for enemies in the vent to
sneak into your office he causes him to
appear faster
invisible on the cameras can only be
seen when he reaches your left doorway
close the door on his face to send him
back to the darkness invisible to
cameras can only be seen right doorway
okay so same things here left right
uh
click him quickly otherwise he will get
in your face with an air horn agitating
sound sensitivity okay
he climbs through the ducts uh
occasionally activate and ask for five
fast coins you can alternatively use the
heater to cause him to malfunction okay
climbs in the vents but can avoid the
vent snare listen to his voice shut the
vent door before he gets
through
interesting so
right so that
oh god
lefty too much noise too far away for
the music box but the global music box
can calm him down i don't even remember
where the music box is
whatever let's try this
i need those instructions again i need
oh god they're not going to give it to
me okay so
if i recall
oh hi
oh that was fast okay you need that
oh
i'm so not okay
uh you go away
okay
so ventilation you're gonna go through
there no matter what we
whoa
you're gonna go through there that is
much faster than i thought it would be
because i feel like that's
oh hi you uh heater
oh god what is that
oh right the heater makes people oh god
the heater makes them go whoa my god
[Music]
thanks
oh boy thank you
what can i do for you uh could i get
some soundproofing i guess i don't know
oh [ __ ]
uh oh god what does that mean what did
that mean what do you mean i don't know
what that means
i don't
oh god okay so that
that that's fine i think i yeah i eat
him okay
my god
right freddy left hallway forgot about
that
click him all right right right
right right good
god
i feel like a baby i feel like just a
wee baby i feel like the tiniest little
baby
god it feels like forever since i've
done this there's so many different
things that i gotta i gotta address and
i gotta get to
try that again
let me
actually let me look at that okay so
that's why those guys were more often
they weren't at one they were at ten
ned bears at one he's pretty much fine
same with molten freddy he doesn't move
that fast but lefty is the one that i
can't forget about either
because he's gonna be there
all the time
right
and
noise and heat okay
let's try that again
let's try that again let's try it again
all right
so
the trick of it is do i turn off the
desk fan right away
is that like the strategy or is the desk
fan better
i don't remember
okay anyway left hallway i don't know if
i need coins for anything here just
curious
can you oh god
can you close the vent
i saw oh god help me
all right i don't know if you can close
it you totally can't so you can close
the vent from the camera which is
helpful
there he is okay he gets closer than
that
um
i think
right
yeah he does but that's okay
this seems weirdly slower
okay
oh my goodness no deposit five point you
freddie doesn't look right thank you for
depositing five coins
you're welcome thank you oh god oh god
okay so freddie's getting closer i don't
remember where his actual threat
of being close is
i don't think he's there yet
i do not think he's there
oh good oh my god i got that just at the
last second
okay where is you're over there you're
fine
um i don't know where
let's say for example
lefty would be
i'm forgetting something
the fan is off
thank you for depositing five coins
okay so far so good so far so nothing
i'm forgetting something aren't i
oh
that
that i'm forgetting something
i am 100 forgetting something
absolutely forgetting something
the power generator
right
you can generate power
or at least like it'll slow down your
consumption of power or something like
that i don't remember exactly which
oh my god
okay
right
but it's loud
that's the problem with it
he might be there not
okay
okay easy
i need to not run out of power i'm about
to run out of power
but i just i just gotta be careful with
it
okay that's okay
i'm gonna turn on the fan for just a
second
okay
so this is manageable he's going down
the wrong path up there get rid of you
turn off the fan turn on the generator
i don't think it'll ever make the power
go up but i think it will offset like
one thing of power consumption right is
that my thinking is that correct
i think so
so far so nothing
he's fine
so far so good
oh my god
got that turn on the power ac
actually no i don't want to turn that on
with power generator and the fan
that's what i want
where we have good
okay
turn fan off
almost there
almost there turn fan on just to
celebrate
i did it
[Music]
oh man
oh man
that was nerve wracking and there was
barely anything in there there was
barely
anything
in that one
but i did technically beat it
so that one i could either um i could
either go up because there's more
difficult version of that with another
bear and another bear and then there's
an even harder version of that
and then there's pay attention which
i don't really know what i'm supposed to
be paying attention to
oh my goodness and then ladies night and
creepy crawlies all of these are split
up uh basically in a way that gets you
introduced to all of the individual
animatronics and start to understand
their mechanics on an individual level
which is the difficulty
that gets bigger and bigger and then it
gets horrible and horrible and i do know
that there are certain number of these
that are pretty easy to beat even at
level 20 mode
but i'm not there yet i am
not there yet
by the way um side note part two of
inspace with markiplier is launching on
monday it's going to be a premiere at 12
pacific there's a link in the
description set a reminder because we
can all watch it premiere live together
if you're there i highly encourage you
to and i can't wait for you to i
i can't freaking wait
for you to see part two i am so
unbelievably excited for you to see part
two part one the response was exactly
what i was hoping for but part two oh
you guys are gonna love it okay so what
i'm gonna do now is i'm actually gonna
instead of pay attention i'm gonna go to
ladies night
uh because i wanna get a more diverse
spread of
characters here
yes set a reminder if you set a reminder
it'll give you a notification definitely
when it's about to go live uh but just
so you don't forget set a reminder down
there
over on the link in the description
below and then you'll get a notification
when it's gonna go up
all right
ladies night we got chica while chica
doesn't care if the music box is wound
up she can grow tired of the music
selection this when the sounds of pots
and pans stop you only have a short
amount of time to change the music
good
uh put your freddy fazbear mask on when
she sneaks into your room to fool her
and make her go away unlike the other
animatronics in the vent once mangled
reaches the vent opening he will never
leave use the vent snare to prevent her
from making it that far jj she will try
to sneak in through the side van close
the door wait till you hear a thud if jj
slips in she will disable the door
controls temporarily okay
with her chica she climbs through the
air vents but may get stuck when trying
to enter your office use a vent snare
make it stuck i love i love that
so technically isn't there a strategy
where she gets stuck and that prevents
anything from gum a binder that would be
hilarious
jack ochika
when the office heats up she will appear
in both halls at the same time close
both doors to make her vanish this won't
work if the office is 100 degrees or
more
okay circus baby purchased her plushed
away from the prize counter when she
appears in the right hall to avoid her
attack the office door cannot stop her
she will approach from one of the
hallways listen for which hallway she is
in and shut the appropriate door
happy frog air vents audio lure to keep
her in place she is immune to the heater
audio lure
i forgot about that check the left and
right hallways when then double click on
the wet floors
hit the wet floor sign i forgot about
that
oh
god
okay
fun time she will appear at random to
distract you there is no way to avoid
her god damn you fun time chica
all right scrap baby she will appear on
the opposite side of your she will
appear on the opposite side of your
office desk when she moves using oh
right literally sitting across from me
okay
yeah
all right oh yeah phone guy
oh my god i forgot about phone guy um
[Music]
okay
review chica
pots and pans
freddy mask
watch the vents watch the right vent
air vents don't keep it too hot both
sides plush toy that's why i need 10
fast coins listen for ballora
vents doesn't get affected by the heater
rock star both signs both sides wet
floor sign
fun time for fun time and scrap baby
okay
here we go
i got it i got it guys i got it i got it
okay
so chicken
oh god what is that
is that is that something i have no idea
okay audio lure i don't know what the
audio lure even is
oh pots and pans
whoa hello
oh god pots and pans
oh
okay we're okay
turn on the power generator because i
don't think that there's anything that i
i need
to check
for that just yet you're okay
god the pots bits
i'm dead
no i'm okay i'm okay
i'm okay
i don't have near oh i don't have enough
coins give me coins oh my god give me
coins please coins please please i'm
begging you coins one more
uh bye
got it okay good we're good i think
we're good there
i don't think i need coins for anything
else
i hear them still going oh god what am i
doing
why oh my god i forgot about that
uh looks like you might be going over
there one of those is not affected by
that
you're okay there
you're oh god oh what floor sign where
is it where is it where's the wet floor
sign is it over there i don't know
uh
oh
come on
that's hard to click i remember that
being an [ __ ] now that is not fun
okay where's they in the vents okay at
least some of you might be affected by
that
power is not great but okay
okay there's an uh there's definitely
something that i'm forgetting here
i just don't remember what it is okay
you're fine there you're gonna be
blocked
that's fine
uh
oh i'm not clicking on you i
likes you okay good so i'll do you a
favor all right
uh power please
okay who you're both coming there which
is fine uh
okay so far so good
shockingly
so far so good
okay who's okay you're all coming up
there
which is fine
i don't know why i'm getting coins but i
am
so
there you go
we're still stuck there
oh okay so that's good
but i think that um
chica is not going to be
thwarted by that
i'm not who
just got thwarted by that chica was
thwarted by that
that okay yeah that's too hard to click
i hate how hard to click that is
it's like a triple click or a quadruple
click
or something like that
i forgot about you oh my god chica
i'm dead
am i dead
i'm not dead i'm not dead i completely
forgot about that
i'm fine
okay i'm fine
i haven't seen jj at all which is okay
in my book
are you guys you're there still stupid
still stuck
okay
it's hard to click
not doing it
still hurting
her
okay
okay
all right
hey
look at that
hey look at that
okay
game theory just dropped a video about
me what the hell is that about wait hold
on what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean
what do you mean
what is that
what is this video
ah interesting
fascinating
it's just like one time
oh wow
he made a video about in space with
markiplier i knew i knew that he played
it um
that's so nice
hang on one second let me see if i can
uh
that's so sweet hold on one moment let
me uh
that's so nice
that's so sweet
oh
i uh
i kind of want to watch this i i
i wasn't attending this but matpat is
just such a sweetheart and i'm kind of
curious of what this video is um if i
watch this it might have spoilers for
part one but there shouldn't be anything
for part two because
matpat has not seen part two so i'm
gonna i think i've actually got to watch
this uh if you guys want to watch it for
yourself uh the game theorist if you
don't know about the game theorist where
are you who are you what have you done
um
yeah it's very sweet
so uh
maybe i'll give it a little try maybe
maybe um
if you guys are down for it maybe i'll
give it a little a little lookie-loo a
little bit of a looky-loo you know what
i mean maybe a little bit of a
little bit of a lookie-loo you know
could uh could do a bit of a lucky loo
okay here we go
i did not know that this was going to be
coming out i was like dead serious i
this just got uploaded like a few
minutes ago uh so watching this is is my
first time even knowing that this was
going to happen so i'm very curious of
where this is going to go um
obviously all support to matpat and the
game theorist if you want to check that
out leave a like on this video i also
want to say that all the people that
have done play throughs of space thank
you so much those of you who have
watched it on stream if you guys see
anyone that is streaming uh be on the
lookout for when part two drops if you
see anyone that is streaming or does a
video about it leave a like like show
some love it's incredible i'm so honored
that people would uh so this is kind of
a an interesting little surprise for me
so here we go
do you even know who you are i do and
soon they will too
hello internet welcome to game theory
the show that's officially decided that
a multi-choice youtube series is in fact
a video game that's right today we're
talking about the wibbly wobbly tiny
whiny story of in space with markiplier
the follow-up to mark's first youtube
original a heist with markiplier both
projects have you teaming up with mark
to navigate through a choose your own
adventure style quest of course things
don't go as planned and the resulting
chaos has you whip panning your way
through a sea of interesting places and
people you gotta separate your bones
from your meat otherwise
you're gonna get chaos
i mean the man has a great point there
you do have to separate the bones from
the meat and in outer space things get
even more interesting engines are
looking good captain really the
supporting cast for this thing is out of
this world chef's kiss 10 out of 10.
speaking of things that are out of this
world seamless segue for the win as you
might expect from anything sci-fi in
space doesn't just mess with branching
pathways but also with time loops
wormholes and the multiverse all
concepts that boil down to one thing
lore now if this was any other project i
probably wouldn't be making this video
sure there's lots of branching paths and
cool easter eggs hidden inside of them
but the lore would be right there for
you available for anyone that's diligent
enough to dig through the various
decision trees but this is a markiplier
project and if you've ever seen my past
videos on markiplier the projects he
touches tend to have a bit more bubbling
underneath the surface for the
uninitiated markiplier has quite a large
amount of lore on his channel with
characters ranging from wilford wharf
stash to darkiplier characters that
started off as little one-off jokes that
eventually became fully fleshed out with
their own backstories and motivations
we've dissected some of this lore before
but within space part 1 being
markiplier's biggest and most ambitious
project ever i suspected that these
personalities might be making a return
sure you can play through in space to
kill off mark as many times as you want
totally fine if that's what you want to
do great go for it but there were also
moments that kept setting off my
theorist senses namely the constant
paradox
or one-off lines that seem to imply a
greater history to this world lines like
do you even know who you are sprinkled
throughout told me that there was a
mystery here a big reveal waiting in the
wings to happen in part two so i dug in
and let me tell you there is a lot
hidden here buckle up theorists cause
i'm about to launch your brains into the
stratosphere i think i've figured out
what the main climax of inspace with
markiplier part 2 is gonna be and
despite all the hints that mark's been
throwing out i don't think it's what
you'd expect
i i'm gonna pause this for just a second
because i am incredibly curious as to
what he is going to say here i am what
he says in this video he does not know
where part two goes
so i am curious and i will not confirm
or deny anything that he says also if
you don't want any kind of guess or
spoiler for part two
do not watch
for now and then come back to it
afterwards
later on i'm gonna keep watching because
i'm curious uh and and like i said part
two there's a link to it down in the
description below if you want to get a
reminder for that go there and also
there's a trailer
for part 2 that you may not have seen
where the multiverse is littered with
the corpses of your failures all right
here we go
also before i get too deep into this i'm
sure some of you are thinking that i've
cheated that i'm gonna spoil the ending
because i was in the show the truth is i
wouldn't be making this video if i did
know the ending mark is a good friend
and he's worked really hard on this
project i wouldn't want to ruin the
surprise that he has for his audience
when working on the show i never saw the
whole thing i was only exposed to the
parts that i was in tldr here i don't
want to act as the tom holland of this
mcu markiplier connected universe this
is being treated like any other video
that we do we're dissecting clues that
are presented within the videos that we
have at our disposal and that's it we're
not pulling from any extra insider
information so in my initial playthrough
of in space on gt live i pointed out
that we needed to be wary of celsie the
head of cryo played by pamela horton
alright so uh pam always important to
note with these episodes as we've done
in a previous theory pam tends to be the
same character in different settings you
see pam's most notable character to date
has been celine from who killed
markiplier a four-part murder mystery
released back in 2017 about a friendly
poker night that goes south and when it
comes to markiplier lore this series
really is the foundation for his mcu as
it provides us the backstories for
pivotal recurring characters in it a
pompous jerk named actor mark dies yep
that is officially what he's known as in
the canon and the primary suspects
include his childhood friend damien the
mayor i know i'm supposed to be a leader
in this scenario but i can't help but
feel lost damien's sister and mark's
ex-wife the mystical celine something
tells me this seemingly significant
event is actually a footnote in a much
larger mystery unfolding in our midst
and the wacky mustache twirling
gun-toting kernel
life needs a bit of madness hey chap it
turns out actor mark's death was all
part of a greater plan thanks to some
magic within the mansion actor mark is
able to take over damien's body while
damian and celine both take over your
body which gives rise to mark's most
infamous character the red and blue
filtered darkiplier meanwhile seeing his
friends die and come back to life takes
a bit of a toll on the old colonel which
causes him to go mad all these
characters then recur throughout
markiplier's other narrative videos when
darkiplier suddenly shows up in an
ending of a date with markiplier we know
that he's connected to damien and celine
thanks to the same red blue filter and
the recurring theme of choice
and the colonel story continues in
wilford mother loving wharf stash where
we see the detective from who killed
markiplier hunting down the now deranged
colonel transformed into the reality
warping killer slash journalist wilford
worf stash name after name after name
just so you could distance yourself from
the real name you should be called
murderer wow
there we all are how the hell did you do
that so when in space features a
surprise appearance by wilford boogeying
down to 70s music wearing largely the
same outfit he was wearing in mother
loving morph stash you know that these
cannons are going to be somehow
connected given those connections i did
some digging on pam's new character
celsi just before the release of in
space part one mark posted some photos
to instagram showing the credentials for
various crew members aboard the ship
bert gunther and of course celsie but
did you notice anything different about
celsie's card all of them have their
faces scratched out but celsius instead
of the typical black is scratched out in
white with a very distinctive blue and
red accent a motif that's been used time
and time again whenever dark applier is
kicking around you also very obviously
have a name connection celsi celine very
similar so could these two actually be
the same character could celsie in this
new series actually be the seer celine
from who killed markiplier the answer is
surprisingly no mark has definitely put
some parallels in there but i couldn't
find a linchpin to say that the two were
definitely one of the same so why put in
a red herring like that well just
because celsi isn't selene doesn't mean
that celine isn't aboard the ship during
in space if you choose to fire all
weapons at the wormhole mark opens a
locker that's covered in post-it notes
you've got references to tiny box tim
worf stash mark's undying love for the
captain but take a look at the bottom
posted it says doreen celsi connection
okay we've talked about celsi but then
who is doreen this one's not super
complicated on our tablet we have a list
of crew members with the name doreen l
whittaker on it later when an old woman
glitches into reality to offer us some
cookies mark refers to her as mrs
whitaker so think it's pretty safe to
say that they're one of the same but
what does that have to do with celsi or
celine for that matter well take a look
at doreen's clothes the outfit doreen's
wearing is a flowy black dress covered
in a celestial pattern stars planets
that kind of thing which is incredibly
similar to the dress that was worn by
the mystical celine throughout who
killed markiplier but that's not all in
one of the secret endings dorine appears
and says some very familiar sounding
lines but that's your choice you always
did have a choice i won't force this on
you you have a choice here celine as a
character has always been about choice
talking about giving us a choice or a
lack of choice that we have so it's
important that doreen is saying these
exact same things and finally doreen
gives us this very important line so mrs
whitaker we need you to get i'm not
married anymore
a fact that gets repeated a couple times
i told you i'm not married anymore why
make us so aware of this detail about a
seemingly random character well it's
designed to point us in the direction of
another character we know the only other
main character within the franchise to
be divorced celine she was divorced from
the actor mark in who killed in short
celsi was the logical stepping stone a
hint from mark to us theorists that
celine was in fact here just not in the
body that we expected her to be in not
in celsi but in doreen so selena's here
and wharf stash is definitely here then
where are the other characters from the
story where are actor mark and most
importantly of all darkiplier well back
in may of 2019 mark released another
video as part of his markiplier
connected universe damien this video if
it wasn't obvious focuses on the
character damien and the frosty limbo
that he and celine exist in after the
events of who killed markiplier in it we
see damian going through a looping cycle
day after day until his routine is
broken by the evil actor mark
narcissistic as ever and obsessed with
having someone play the villain to his
hero you don't realize this place is a
dream a never-ending starring role as
the hero but what is a hero without a
villain you honestly think
that you're the hero in all of this
well of course i am in the end celine
seeds control of darkiplier to damien
alone so he can get his revenge on actor
mark while she goes to rest you can't
come back from this it'll change you
well he did say he wanted me to be the
villain maybe he should be more careful
with his wishes notice the language here
this repeated emphasis on the battle
between a hero and a villain now look at
in space part one at the start of the
story when we're introduced to our head
engineer and primary mark he gives us
lines that seem to imply that we go way
back just like old times here captain
and then later in the majority of the
endings we're confronted by an old
version of mark one who again seems to
share a long history with us friend of
mine oh close confidence i missed our
exchanges of conversation one who
apparently has something to apologize
for i'm sorry about a lot of things and
someone who's been waiting a long time
to try and stop our apparently evil
plans i can't let you win this is the
final confrontation good versus evil the
hero versus the villain when he succeeds
he tells us that it's time to move on
it's all in the past because i beat you
it's weird none of this seems to fit
like i know that we screwed up the
multiverse via our choices as the
captain but it doesn't seem like this is
the way that this character would
respond seems like he's commenting on
things that are outside of the story
that we were presented and he is the
thing is we've seen one character say
all of these lines before repeat all of
these same ideas friend of mine oh close
confidant oh my friend it's all in the
past but that's all in the past good
there's an evil the hero versus the
villain what is a hero without a villain
this isn't just any mark this is actor
mark he's now in the role that he's
always dreamed of he's the hero he's the
one that gets to save the multiverse
from evil mark put it like this during
his breakdown of damien he's in this
world where he gets to play out the
leading role of any story he wants he
can't imagine other people not loving
that he's just a narcissist he can't
even imagine that he's wrong but then
why is mark so determined to defeat us
it seemed like the captain was meant to
just be us the viewer put into this
adventure but i'm not entirely convinced
that that's the case even doreen has us
questioning our identity you can't say
i'm surprised you always were stubborn
do you even know who you are do you feel
like you've been here before or is this
just history repeating itself she knows
us we are damien we are darkiplier
someone celine always thought was
stubborn someone who's been stuck in a
repeating loop of events someone who
keeps being told that they need their
rest just like the signs next to our
cryopod tell us get some sleep you look
tired in fact there's a lot of small
stuff hidden in here too like how in who
killed markiplier we get this line from
the detective maybe i shouldn't have
trusted someone so goddamn gorgeous and
in in space we regularly hear things
like what could never laid eyes on a
creature so handsome and or beautiful we
are once again considered attractive
this is why despite the fans crying out
to see darkiplier as a part of the
series he's yet to show up we've been
inside his body the whole time we've
been looking through his eyes it's also
why actor mark is so determined to beat
us notice what happens during all the
endings of part one were sent to a place
outside the known universe
i know
that's the point a black void with blue
lighting but is it just me or does this
look a little bit familiar like say the
black nothingness with blue that we see
enveloping damien in who killed
markiplier or again in the ending of the
video damien the problem is we don't
remember who we are on multiple
occasions we have celine in the body of
doreen trying to jog our memories makes
you feel like you've been through all
this before
do you understand dearie she's trying to
bring damien to the surface she's trying
to remind him of who he is and what he
has to do and so now with the universe
being rebooted i believe that's exactly
what we're gonna start to see damien
beginning to remember darkiplier
becoming who he was meant to be the
reboot means the stage is now set for
actor mark and darkiplier to have their
final showdown after all these years
they can finally put to rest this quest
for revenge that's been keeping them
going for so long recently mark released
a teaser for part two full of codes that
translated to quote seven gods aligned a
key formed from their union the lock
hides in time seven gods you say remind
me how many characters were in who
killed markiplier oh yeah seven celine
damien wharf stash actor mark even the
detective the chef and the butler the
last three of which appear as frame
perfect glitches in the endings of in
space basically what i expect we're
building towards is a reunion of all
these characters towards the true canon
ending of the whole series an ending
that'll put an end to the darkiplier
actor mark feud or maybe reverse time
back to undo the events of who killed
markiplier that is why we've been
getting all these noir themed hints
throughout his recent videos it's a
callback to the overall tone and noir
moments of who killed markiplier we're
building to the climactic ending of the
markiplier cinematic universe an ending
that leads us back to where it all began
but hey that's just a theory a game
theory i'll see you in space on may 2nd
i am neither confirming nor denying
anything in that video i am just honored
that matpat made it in the first place
please go send
the game theorist all the love in the
world for that one i am honored that
they take the time to do stuff like this
because it is just like it's it's i
wh why would he take the time to do it
leave a like on that video it's on the
game theorist channel it's just so fun
to see someone dig in that deep to
something like
it's just like it's an honor it's i'm
just freaking honored so seriously mad
fat thank you so much i'm sorry i didn't
smash your perfect pokemon
i just oh man i'm just so tickled i
cannot wait for you guys to see part two
i cannot wait
it premieres on monday
this monday in two days in two days
almost exactly two days from now
for two premieres
and oh man just
i'm tickled to death i'm just tickled uh
i just love it i just i freaking love it
it's so
cool to see
the link to part two premiere page is in
the description below if you have not
set a reminder for that go now
and set it and then come back here i am
gonna go back to ultimate custom night i
am going to keep playing that that is
definitely happening but for right now
definitely go set a reminder on the
premiere page because we can all watch
it live together and then immediately
after the premiere the choices will
appear and you go and it's just like the
gates open and flood
flood into it like it's two days away oh
my god
i just can't wait it's ah
i'm so god damn excited for you to see
it i can't
i'm so happy
with how it's come together i'm so
happy
with everything that has gone into it
with how it has turned out
oh my god
i want to talk about it so badly
i want to talk about it so badly
you guys don't understand
you guys don't understand it is such an
honor to be able to do stuff like this
it is an honor to
i got to write a comment on this video
just like
i
i confirm nothing i deny nothing
or whatever
seriously
you all will have to watch
part two to find out just how
horrendously wrong
matpat
is
or right
now
uh
is on monday may 2nd
can't wait for you all to see it and
thanks
so much matt
for
uh being a part of it
nothing but love
nothing but love
except love for your quote perfect
pokemon
sorry a few typos
okay there we go
definitely leave a like on that video
it's
it's so sweet
it's so sweet it's just sweet of them
give love to that video and then
it's
oh that's great all right anyway sorry i
i know i've been distracted i've been
distracted a lot
you know i just want to talk
that's all i want to do i've been
wanting to do that for so long now
because as you've noticed i have not
been posting videos regularly in the
interim number one of which the reason
i've been doing that is because i didn't
want to uh saturate the channel with
content that was not related to uh in
space with markiplier because frankly
i'm extremely proud of it and i worked
two years on it i was taking a break i
was i wasn't even taking a break because
there was still so much work to be done
uh on the show
that i had to buckle down i only got
done with the final touches of part two
uh yesterday
that's just
god i i'm just gonna take a few minutes
to talk about this because i i've wanted
to i've wanted nothing more than to talk
about it and and like it's it's on the
eve the eve eve of being the day of the
release of part two and finally after
part two comes out i am gonna do a big
stream talking about it
uh probably the following weekend i
don't know exactly what day but you know
i want people to get a chance to
actually see it and go through it before
i talk about it um
god i just i'm so proud
i'm so proud i'm so proud of myself i'm
so proud of all the team that's made it
i'm so proud of like just you guys for
enjoying it i'm so proud of everything
about it
so it's such a deep
deep feeling of satisfaction
that words cannot describe
this is why i do
what i do this is why i make the videos
that i make that's why i'm driven
to make things cause it's it's beautiful
it's beautiful
it's so wonderful
i it just is
it's wonderful i'm not talking about the
show the show is
your opinion on the show beautiful i
think it's beautiful but like i'm
talking about the experience the ability
for me
and especially like i've been doing
youtube now for 10 years
10 years
that's a long time
i can measure my progress as like a
creator as as a youtuber as as a
filmmaker now and as like
all these things that i didn't know i
could do and now i can
with confidence i know i'm like i can
make this [ __ ] i can
it's just
oh oh people tell me matpat just made a
video yes i know i just watched it um
anyone here that has not given love to
that video go give love to that video
but
ah
it's wonderful
it's everything i could have hoped for
you know i always talk about this about
the things that i make i look back at is
let's say for example the fall of
slender man for those of you have seen
my first uh i guess you would call it a
sketch or short film or whatever on
youtube um i look back at that and i
don't i don't i don't look at it with a
critical eye in terms of like belittling
my work i i can look at it with a
critical eye and be like oh man
technically it's terrible
the lighting's terrible the camera's
terrible the setup's terrible uh
everything about it you know the editing
is is mediocre but honestly i never look
at it like that because i always look
back at the things that i made and i'm
extremely proud um just because
it was the best i could do at the time
i've had a chance to talk about this i'm
i i did a video with uh anthony padilla
with bro god i have not been able to
collab with people for a while um
you know i was on a podcast
just like being able to talk about it
being able to talk about the corridor
guys you know corridor digital corridor
crew
like oh man
just being able to say how
wonderful it is and to echo the
sentiment that it's not that i'm special
you know what i mean it's not
especially looking at me 10 years ago
you guys saw like pictures of me i
looked like a nerd because i was a big
nerd i didn't know what i was doing and
i'm not saying i'm not a nerd now
because i am absolutely and i don't know
everything that i'm doing but
just because i wanted it so badly to be
able to do that
you know
i have it
i have it now i have it and i don't know
where i'm even going to take it now
because i've got so many other things
that i want to make and i've got so many
other steps in front of me and that's
like the most exciting thing to me is
that i see this path ahead of me of like
things that i can make in this landscape
of of making things and it's just like
it's overwhelming sometimes not in terms
of being like oh god i have so many
choices it's just like
i'm happy you know
i am
i'm extremely extremely happy
and i i
cannot wait for you to see
this show part two huh
i cannot wait
thank you guys
seriously thank you i do this for you i
do it for myself and for you there's a
reason why i want to get this stuff out
for free you know there's no cost to it
you know it's uh it's all there for you
i did this for you and me and all of us
and everything
because it's it's it's
it's worth it it's worth it to make
stuff like this it's worth it to pursue
what you want to do to artistically go
out there it's worth the work it's worth
all of it because that's what really
matters is like
digging into yourself finding who you
are and finding what you can do because
you don't know what you can do until you
start doing it i encourage anyone out
there who is looking to pursue something
like this or something else or anything
that you want to do creatively to
literally start taking the steps towards
it whatever step you take you don't know
what the road is it's just forward
because you don't know where it's going
to end up i took my first step in making
videos and even before that i took my
first steps in creating things like i
didn't just land on youtube videos i
started
trying to make a comic like my brother
you know i tried to art i switched
degrees for a few moments
for one semester into art school from
engineering because i wanted to pursue
some creative stuff i tried writing i
tried game programming um i talked with
the corridor guys i didn't even want to
do let's plays at first you know i
wanted to make short films you know why
my channel is called markiplier do you
know some of you may know but do you
know
it's because i wanted to make videos
where i play all of the characters short
films where i play all the characters i
wanted to multiply
myself
mark
multiplier markiplier
and i'm doing
some of that
now
i have i have my goal my goal i have it
and so few people can say that but it's
like
that's that's
yeah
just take the first steps
seriously it's never too late it is
never too late
and and just like keep digging challenge
yourself push yourself
do things that you don't know if you can
do it because that's the only way you
grow
yeah
anyway
thank you seriously thank you all right
i've got a lot more ultimate custom
night to do this this stream has gotten
away with
away from me because i've been doing
things that i i i
but i am going back to ultimate custom
night i swear right now in fact right
now i am
so here we go god
uh
all
right uh there's a link in the
description that leads to the premiere
page of part two it's on my channel set
a reminder be there i'll be there when
we all watch you together live
it'll be a good time and send matpat
love that was the other thing all right
we're back we did bears attack and we
delayed god this is such a shift
it's fine it's fine it's fine
all right bears attack ladies night i
want to do pay attention next uh because
it's a it's another
different smorgasbord of animatronics
that i have to deal with that i don't
know if i can deal with but i will deal
with them
i love you guys
thank you
thank you so much for being here with me
through thick and thin and now you're
gonna be here with me as i work my way
up to maybe 50 20.
maybe i don't know i literally set aside
all of today to try to do this i don't
know if i'm going to ever do it but at
least i can make some progress on it
okay
all right so we got bb
side vent
uh
same thing as jj so bb and jj are the
same i just gotta look for those beady
dead eyes in the side pen uh marionette
keep the music box wound okay if i don't
keep the global music box on okay easy
enough
slumped over in your office do not shine
your light on him if he was sitting up
you must use your flashlight to reset
him okay
good to know
c button to catch a fish otherwise it'll
lock your monitor funtime foxy check his
curtain to see when his show is set to
begin then be sure right check every
hour on the hour i remember i said be
sure to watch this camera the exact time
to postpone the show otherwise that is
when your game will end
all right helpy i know healthy okay
[Music]
keep the noise down you'll begin to hear
his symbols crashing faster and faster
eventually leading to a jump scare
uh close the ad to
do that i think it's enter to do that
she will appear random to distract you
no way to avoid her afton will attack
once per night making a lot of noise and
causing the lights to flicker close the
right vent door to stop him okay so i
need to check
look for the side vent keep the music
box wound
don't shine unless he is standing up
see to catch a fish check for the show
time healthy don't make too much sound
ads fun time chica and then
afton
okay got it let's do it
let's see what happens
mr hippo story i do know about that okay
he's slumped over right now
okay so i want to keep
actually i cannot keep okay 3am got it
oh oh god what
what
i forget okay no one's going through the
ducks
but 3 a.m okay so 3 a.m is
every 45 seconds i believe is when 3am
rolls by
my god
hello
all right good to see you oh god i
forgot about the phone call why is my
wibbly i don't know okay every hour on
the hour i need it
2 15 i think to be here is what it oh
god oh god oh god
okay
oh [ __ ] well i'm boned
i recognize you
but i'm not afraid of you
not anymore
anymore do you even know who you are
okay that was a lot god uh
all right
good to know
let's try this again yes this is live
let's try this again so wha i forgot
about the winding of the music box that
is the one thing that i did forget and i
need to check this
side path uh 1am okay
so that's good
because at the very least that's soon
and then i will be done with that
forever i need to regularly turn off
the fan
okay
does changing the music cause a problem
i don't know
1am almost time almost out oh i almost
forgot again
it's almost time for 1 a.m showtime
here we go
be there i'm here i'm here yay i made it
okay now i never need to worry about him
again
i think
oh okay so i think i think that's done
for that there you go funk
bonk your noggin whoa okay
good god okay hello this is sudden
all right so i never need to worry about
william afton again
or springtrap i
shut up go away
springtrap right
right
am i crazy about that i think that's
true
oh my god oh
my brain is trying to wrap it around
all this nonsense oh hey he
okay
okay all right
both this is a lot to pay attention to
but it's not impossible there's no one
going through the ducks i don't think so
and so long as i keep the desk fan on
and off
that keeps the noise down and my power
consumption
at least pretty regular
i think anyway
not gonna bother with you
okay it's just a lot of patterns that
overlap that i need to worry about and
then a system of
hierarchical priorities
right
forget what the problem is if you do old
man wrong i think he just locks your
monitor
okay power is good
power's good everyone's good
we're all good
no there's no show is it oh my god there
is another show
oh god that's right oh god is it i
forget oh god no okay it wasn't 2 45 oh
my god
i missed that okay it's uh three uh
three o'clock would be oh you're right
you're right you're so right
you know what you're right here we go
and here we are
okay and 5 a.m i forgot he does that
again
oh my god okay okay okay
anyway
oh i forgot about that okay
3 45.
hey listen i i had an idea if you happen
to get caught and want to avoid getting
stuck into a freddy suit
try playing dead you know go limp
345. maybe you don't think that you're
an mp costume instead
340. if they think you're an empty
costume they might try to
stuff a mental skeleton into you
i wonder how that would work
345 okay 345 oh my god not right now
please don't
please don't 345 got it okay 7am i'm
good on that
you're good you're good we're all good
we're all good
we're all good
my god
we're all good we're good thank you for
reminding me about that
chat
thank you for reminding me
okay
power is very good and i think we're
solid we're solid all the way we're
solid all the way
we're all the way solid 100 solid
and boom
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god that was so close on the fun
time foxy funtime foxy is the bane of my
existence every single
time
i'm fine
intermission
oh i forgot about this
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
foreign
foreign
[Music]
i just want to know
like whose idea was it
to put that in
was that scott's idea
to put these in
who's i it just doesn't
that doesn't gel with me
that that was
scott's idea to put that in i just don't
feel that it doesn't seem right it seems
very wrong
anyway okay so next up is creepy
crawlies
level one so mangle right vent snare
same with the vent snare
uh he will appear in your office poised
to attack throw on the freddie mask to
make leave again okay
music box
spring trap
close the vent door to send him away
i think he doesn't he still gets stopped
by the
vent snare
doesn't he
toward the end opening a bend in the
wall in front of you doesn't he anyway
phantom mangle when you see him on
monitor quickly close it or he will
appear in your office and create an
audio disturbance
entered difficult to see on the vent
radar he will make his way towards your
office listen for the sounds
cue of squeaking metal then close the
vent okay he's difficult to see on the
radar
is that mean impossible i don't know
okay this is all vent stuff that's easy
enough um
audio lure audio lure
can you do an audio lure i don't even i
don't even remember what the audio lure
is okay and then not too much noise and
then molten freddie climbs in the vents
avoid
the vent snare listen for his voice and
shut the venture okay so it's a lot of
vent stuff here that's what creepy
crawlies is all about it's pretty much
all vent stuff the only thing that is in
the physical
office itself is
uh
phantom mangle
man marionette i believe
all these other ones are air duct and
music man
yeah everything else is air duct okay so
i really need to pay attention to the
air duct the vent and
music box and look out for phantom
mangle
okay easy enough
can do
go
[Music]
and bonnie was bonnie on there
wait what was bonnie on there
what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean okay so that can push
him back or a heater can push it back
for some reason i don't know why but it
can
um both i've already forgotten
everything that i need to do music box
right
keep that wound
and then check this okay you're going
there i forget which one can be affected
by what
but i'm sure it will be obvious as time
goes on
uh
that thankfully i can do that from
anywhere
okay you're coming there that's good oh
god oh god bonnie that's right you did
you did say bonnie i forgot about bonnie
you're absolutely right
i did i was like bonnie you got what
happened
oh you got trapped by that okay you're
good there keep i can keep this wound
anywhere that is very nice
okay you're coming there
i don't want you oh god oh god
he's coming through okay you're all fine
there
okay
let's try to get him there
whoa what is that
what is that what is that
oh my oh right he's hard to see
i forgot about that the squeak
right
right right right right right got it got
it got it got it
okay
oh [ __ ] how'd you get through
i don't know
you're good okay then snare is okay
who's coming through here you're still
good let me see if i can push them back
a bit
okay
okay
i'm not doing good on power definitely
it looks like i might have to do the
other side to that one
maybe you're closer
whoa who did i get
oh i keep forgetting that like
the actual snare will stop them okay but
it's not stopping that dude
right okay
what
okay
i don't need to look there i'm fine
there everything's good
everything is a-okay
huh
what
did i get
i did i did i'm good okay we're good
it's too much it's too much to look at
it's too much to think about my brain is
breaking my brain okay let's push it
back a bit
okay
audio lure is there uh what audio audio
lure i don't know
i don't know
i'm gonna run out of power
i think i can afford using the generator
a bit
oh my how did you get in
how'd you get in
how
oh my god i'm so screwed
i'm so screwed i'm so screwed i'm
screwed i'm screwed i'm screwed dude
right you
i'm so screwed
i'm so screwed
i'm so screwed
i don't hear smashing slamming but i
know it ain't good
okay
oh god
oh god
if i can just last 10 seconds
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that was stressful as hell
god that was stressful okay so i had
more power than i thought
i i thought i might be running out but
i'm okay
i'm all right
oh
i hated that
but but apparently music man wasn't as
bad of a threat as i thought he would be
i thought like the moment that i started
making a lot of noise that he would be
there okay
no that's 20s no that's not good old
friends uh classic a classic
classic
oh i don't like that
[Music]
chaos
chaos chaos
of course
chaos
chaos you gotta separate the bones from
the meat otherwise
you gotta get chaos have you ever said
how good of an actor matpat is okay
so i did all of the baseline challenges
the basic ones the basic [ __ ] ones what
i want to do now
is i want to kind of selectively pick
some of these that i know i did not get
exposure to so i understand what their
mechanic
actually is
or maybe i could just do bears attack
too
oh it does add a few more oh
boy
chaos you want chaos
i could do chaos
i could do chaos
do you want chaos i'll let you decide
life is yours to choose after all
[Music]
all right chaos it is let me look at
this
so toy freddy
sits in parts and service room playing
five nights with mr hugs on his big
screen tv click the cams right i have to
click the cameras on that one
then be sure that the appropriate door
is closed
playing a game within a game that's
hilarious all right
marionette that's his music box same
thing about that
nightmare freddy um flashlight to shine
on them before freddie appears okay uh
nightmares you hear the sounds left and
right that's fine uh
both at the same time
but only when the office heats up so i
just can't let the office get above 100
degrees and we'll be okay whole main
consequences
c button catch the fish when his mini
game appears otherwise he will lock your
monitor got it ballora
uh listen i didn't even hear ballora
last time approaching so maybe i got
that trash in the game
hey trash in the gang all right uh vent
people
rock star freddy will ask for fast coins
rockstar bonnie search the cameras find
his guitar
right
[Music]
that's annoying all right rockstar foxy
all right
okay so this is just increasing his
thing i think when he's at a zero
like the the pair still appears but the
risk of dying is extremely low all this
does is increase the risk of dying so if
you never click on it you're fine
music man
[Music]
chip fun time foxy and then okay once
per night so i don't need to check
any of the curtains
i need to play the game
keep the music box
flash flashlight close doors play old
man close doors pay attention to the
event
click helpy
get uh fast coins oh my god rockstar
bonnie find the guitar don't click on
the parrot keep the noise down close the
ads
get distracted and then
vent on the right
easy
[Music]
here we go
all right so
events let's just try to keep the audio
lure
oh my god i forgot about you already oh
my god okay
what
whoa my god what in the world
don't be shy
what
what
me
excuse me
excuse me
this is chaos one
okay all right
okay
let's try that
again okay trying again
oh where's the music box why is this not
here uh where do you you need this door
okay
i got it
oh my god go away
okay you're their music box this this
vent system put that there whatever you
need your guitar where could it be
oh my god close that there's the guitar
oh my god that's there put the
flashlight there and poof and catch that
and okay we're good turn the fan back on
this just oh my god close that put that
there who's there
someone say excuse me i don't know what
you're talking about
who are you
put that there you're good there uh
stop that there and then turn the fan
off oh my god
oh great
[Music]
that's great
oh my god
oh okay we're good
turn that up oh hey what's up pal how
are you doing
oh my god
okay this is fantastic
oh my god who's there
i don't wanna
no thank you
no thank you
what am i doing oh my god i forgot about
you you're still good there
just do your thing i don't know
i've forgotten everything that i need to
do oh you're still good there okay
why is the lights flashing we're fine
okay
this is insanity and this isn't even
close to 50 50 mode
this is what i remember doing like the
or 50 20. whatever it was i don't know
you still good there yeah you are
oh the ducks oh i almost forgot
go away
i am not doing great on power i know
that so i'm gonna turn the
generator on
you're still good there oh god the
guitar okay guitar
i don't oh my god
please please please there it is okay
you good there turn that on
okay
oh music you still good nope you're not
good anymore there it is okay
okay turn the sound ventilation off or
power generator oh my god
i am not doing great
still good
oh my god stop
i thought i heard something on the right
there
i couldn't tell
i don't know was there something on the
right
no
i don't know
okay
you still good yeah you're still good go
away
this is nuts
this is nuts
this is insanity
go away i don't want to talk to you i
might oh my god no
uh-huh
yep
you're so good there
okay
good on power go down power very good on
power
totally fine
nope not today
go down power use box is good you're
still good
go away
almost there
you go away
fan off
close just in case
i thought i thought i screwed myself
[Music]
damn
i don't know why it was bonkers in the
first hour only
that was nuts in just the first hour and
then it got real calm i don't know what
that was about i have no idea
what that was about
like
it didn't make any sense everything was
so crazy i don't know why velour killed
me that quickly
but it must have just been over
overshadowed by all the nonsense that
was happening before
either way okay
chaos one is done
i'm not gonna go for chaos too because
it is just too much more
that i am not ready for
just at this moment i think i'm gonna go
back to bear's attack because i'm gonna
do bears attack two
because it makes it makes golden freddy
harder it adds the nightmare ones
and then it makes ned bear and all the
other ones a little more difficult
unless how many points would this be
this would be a thousand points so i'd
get over a thousand
twenty five hundred to get the sister
location office yeah i'm gonna try for
points here
i know that there are some here that are
easy to deal with
that are technically harmless
like say for example bb is technically
harmless
jj is technically harmless by themselves
um
marionette is easy to deal with because
it's just the music box
spring trap nah um
these are
well man consequences is technically
harmless
[Music]
trash of the gang are technically
harmless
healthy is technically harmless
[Music]
[Music]
um
yeah let's
let's oh phone guy
all right yeah let's uh let's go with
this because this will get me above a
thousand
so it'll be on the way and then i can
build from there
yes
yes i just gotta make sure the music box
is wound
that's the only thing
music man but i'm gonna be making
there's gonna be a lot of noise going on
let's just be let's just be honest
there's gonna be a lot of noise
so
oh well chip you're right l chip and oh
and rockstar chica you're right or
funtime chica you're right and if i
don't click
on the bird two thousand
okay
that's good
that's good
i'm i'm not
[Music]
but
night marionette ah no
phantoms are they harmless oh they are
harmless
okay
yeah these are harmless
that's 2600
that'll get me to where i need to be
mr hippo
i'm okay
i'm all right
i'll leave that this is 2600 afton
that's true i guess i could just close
it
no let's do let's do this let's do this
let's just do this all i got to worry
about is the music box
i think
i think i think
i i think
here we go
just kind of worry about the music box
i think i can make as much noise as i
want
just gotta worry about the music box
oh my god what do i do i completely
forgot i've completely forgotten what i
do what do i do what do i do are you oh
it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
it's fine
oh my god i forgot about that
[Applause]
[Music]
i could just sit here and do nothing i'm
aware of that except for the fact that
the music box is here oh my god my god
oh my god
good
lord
oh my god oh there's a button to skip
that i just need to know what it is
of course you come here oh my god
oh my god
blind get that all right we're good
hello i can't see [ __ ]
hello
dumb face in there
can you not be there every single time
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like unreliable to be able to
actually do that
he always comes when uh it's like they
time it i'm sure they do
i missed it apparently i don't know what
happened go away oh god
no no
how
soothe
i'm doomed
i shouldn't have put
shouldn't put the name i'm blind
quite as long this time
[Music]
the ad right enter
this
okay you're going away you're going away
because you're the only one that's
actually lethal
that i have in this moment
so the other one that i could do if i
wanted to keep everything a little bit
sane
would be to
have
[Music]
i guess
[Music]
i wonder if it's like because i think
it's by a minute 30 that you need to
have one of the plushies if you only
have one of them and you buy the plushie
ahead of time then you're good right
then you're good
right
right
right
right bonnie
bonnie
if i don't check the cove
right if i don't check the cove
bonnie's fine if foxy isn't there bonnie
doesn't do anything
right
right okay
now i don't i
i don't need to do nothing
right
i don't know
go away
why why am i even looking at the camera
i don't even want it
you gotta i forgot you gotta like uh
slam that down when you go up here
i want to get used to some of the
controls you know
yeah you have to like run with the
silent ventilation system otherwise
you're not going to be able to do
anything you got to like put that down
oh no
no
no
no
[Music]
why
why
oh no did you put the music box in there
no
you did oh foxy's in here
the one i did not need
oh my god i oh
god
you [ __ ]
i don't know what to do about that i i
literally am unsure of what to do i
don't i don't know okay so if you're
here that means bon i don't know
i don't know
wait am i stupid am i dumb
i don't know
i don't know
oh
no
i don't know i think it's fine i don't
know
me of course it is of course it is am i
okay i i don't know
who's here
who you
stop no
great
i love this
whoops i gotta get off that screen i'm
doing something to bonnie real bad what
is happening my ventilation that's right
that's why that kept breaking look at
all those coins oh my god
i don't know what uh
the [ __ ] brought in here
but it seems okay
somehow
right
look i don't know
i don't know anything about anything i'm
an idiot clearly
clearly i'm an idiot
so if i'm an idiot you all have to enjoy
my idiocy
[Applause]
nonsense
nonsense
this is nonsense
i i think what i need to do is i need to
quickly like either press on the same
one
that's right i just remembered like you
can clear them by pressing the same one
even even if you're already on that
screen it'll still clear but you do need
to press so
[Music]
i don't know what's happening
i'm doing good on power because i can
just run that generator which is great
i wish the uh
you might need to actually like remap
the enter button not that it's
impossible to click on it but
it does make it a bit difficult
i am getting better at it though i i
would i will say that like some of these
are like muscle memory
back into me
like some of the things that i need to
do this is strange
so you always need you probably need to
hit that first and then reset and then
come there
yeah i think
yeah
okay
yeah the danger comes from like having
the nightmario net or whatever it is
and having all that at the same time
because it doesn't
it does make it so that the flashlight
is like such a tricky thing because you
can only flashlight so many things at
once and some things don't need it you
will kill you will die if you flashlight
it something you won't
okay so there was no risk of dying there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right good good good good good
do we get a movie
yep we do
dear diary
yesterday was so amazing and i met such
a wonderful guy
but i don't think it was meant to last
for my heart belongs to another
he's so amazing and strong and so so
cute
i've been thinking about him all day
and i think he's really into me too
he's the only one for me
i just know it
and
i know just how to get him
look at that top hat
that amazing top hat
he'll be mine by the end of the day i
just know it
i told him that i needed help with my
homework
but once he's there i'll have him
and once i have him he'll be mine
forever
there is only one thing that could
possibly go wrong
the oil
all right well that was horrifying um
good great
so
good
anyway
oh i see it did it did do that but
thankfully somehow i managed to avoid
dying to that i don't know how
i i have no idea how okay
so
i'm gonna go back to the challenges
because i'm i'm gonna slowly work my way
up in terms of skill on some of these
now it won't get me as many points
that's the thing it won't get me as many
points but what will give me
is a steady increase of skill to be able
to beat all of this also there's the mr
hippo
death stories
do you guys want a mr hippo's story or
do you want me to keep climbing on this
well i mean i will obviously keep
climbing on it but we could go through
the mystery hippo stories there's
something like so hilariously funny
about the mystery stories
i don't think it's guaranteed though is
it
all right you know what i'm going to be
mystery about
i forgot about that
i just want the mystery of those stories
i think i think it's like a chance if he
kills you but not a guarantee i don't
know if i can just pull him down towards
i probably can
come here you
be lord
be lord
and kill me
oh there we go
uh it seems that you have met your end
oh what a pity
you know i i don't feel too bad about it
though
after all if it weren't me
it would have just been one of the
others i guess
i'm honestly just glad to be out of
those air ducts you know it's it's not
easy for a hippopotamus to fit up there
and not easy to get down either and
not as young as i used to be as you can
see
i used to be able to do all sorts of
things you're young you're vibrant you
have that sort of pep in your step
uh it reminds me of a conversation i was
having with one of my good friends
orville
we were having a nice picnic one day
i believe it was summer no perhaps it
was
was it the fall yes yes it was the fall
because the leaves had turned already
but i said to orville i i says orville i
have a story to tell you and orville
looked at me you know kind of odd and
and said what's it about i i said to him
not every story has to be about
something orville sometimes a person
just wants to talk why does
everything have to be a story i said to
him he just looked at me and he said
well you you said you had a story and
you know he was quite right i did in
fact i told him i had a story i suppose
if a person just wants to talk then it's
best to not announce that you're telling
a story
telling a story does come with its own
pressures and expectations i i suppose
after all if you're just talking to a
friend and there's no more expectations
than if you were talking into the wind
words by themselves aren't expected to
carry it aren't expected to stick
but if you know if you announce you're
telling a story well then
there'd better be a point to it all you
know
no one wants to sit and listen to
someone ramble on and on and on with
absolutely no end in sight
so you know it's it's good to be mindful
that when you tell someone that you're
about to tell a story that you have
something to say
telling someone that you're gonna tell
them a story is tantamount to asking
them to stop what they're doing and and
pay attention
you're basically saying hey hey hey
buddy stop everything stop what you're
thinking i have a solution to everything
and well i didn't really have any story
to tell
in in hindsight i i probably just
misspoke when i said that i had a story
i think it would have just been better
to tell orville that i wanted to tell
him something rather than tell him that
i had a story but you know even then it
might have put too much importance on
the whole thing
either way it was quite a nice day i
remember i remember that we were
drinking tea
is this what it's like when i just
ramble on for hours and hours and
lead you on with promises that i
definitely have something that's worth
your time but i just keep going and
going forever is that the only one are
there multiple hippo stories
are there multiple hippo stories
[Music]
yeah it is like that okay well good to
know but are are there multiple hippo
stories or was that the only one
there are multiple oh my god okay um
do you want more
do you want more
i can give there's three different oh my
god oh my god
all right fine all right
we're going into this this is a revisit
after all we could see i i do want to
say like i love the fact that there are
secrets he's quick he's booking it
he's moving fast for an old hippo
all right so come on buddy
i'm gonna take this opportunity to go to
the bathroom have met a terrible
terrible demise have fun but uh you know
i i don't feel too bad about it
after all if if it weren't for me it
would have just been from someone else
you know
i guess what i'm trying to say is life
life goes on
well from for everyone else life goes on
not not for you you're you're dead
that's neither here nor there
it reminds me of one summer day in the
park i was having just a delightful
picnic with my good friend orville and i
said to him i said
orville i i have a story and he said to
me what's the significance of the story
and
i said to him orville not every story
has to have significance you know
sometimes uh you know sometimes a story
is just a story if you try to read into
every little thing and find meaning and
everything anyone says you'll just drive
yourself crazy had a friend do it once
wasn't pretty we talked about it for
years and not only that but you'll
likely end up believing something you
shouldn't believe and thinking something
you shouldn't think or assuming
something you shouldn't assume you know
sometimes i said a story is is just a
story so just be quiet for one second of
your life and eat your sandwich okay
of course it was only then i realized i
made sandwiches and
poor orville was having such difficulty
eating it
elephants have those clumsy hands you
know
actually i i suppose that's the problem
they don't have hands at all do they
they're they're all feet and i i
couldn't imagine someone asking me to
eat a sandwich with my feet
now if i recall correctly there was a
bakery nearby
i said to him orville
let me go get you some rye bread
now i'm unsure if elephants enjoy rye
bread but i assure you that orville does
now this was on a tuesday which was good
because rye bread was always fresh on
tuesday they made sourdough bread on
monday and threw it out wednesday
or rather they sold it at a discount for
people wanting to feed the ducks and
then
probably at the end of the day finally
they threw it all out i i don't recall
i do remember a man who would bring his
son to the bakery every wednesday and
then go feed the ducks he would buy all
of the sourdough bread of course you
know you're not supposed to feed the
duck sourdough bread at all it swells up
in their stomach and then they all die
it uh at least at least that's what i've
heard you know i i never saw any ducks
die myself but i did notice a
substantial decrease in the duck
population over the course of a few
years
i just never thought to stop the man and
tell him that he was killing the ducks
by feeding them sourdough bread and if
you want my opinion on the matter
and i told orville this as well if you
want to feed ducks or birds or any kind
for that matter it's best to buy seed i
mean when you think about it breads of
any sort don't occur in nature they
don't grow on trees or spring up from
the bushes
i don't think birds know what to do with
bread what was i saying
oh oh yes yes so i bought orville some
rye bread what a fine day it was
okay thanks bud
oh thank you pal all right i don't think
i'm gonna subject you to another one of
those
because
because we got
we got so much more to go through but i
do remember
there are other animatronics that have
the same thing
where they have a secret to them right
isn't there there are other animatronics
that do that you want another one
i
do you
do i'll do a poll
do you
mr
hippo
third
third time's the charm
i'll do a poll
look
i i don't feel like you know what you're
asking for
uh
okay
look
i'm sorry it's 71 to 29 right now um
look i'm of the no column but even i've
been overruled
all right this is what the revis is all
about this is what
okay
okay
life is yours to choose or whatever oh
my god
okey-dokey
but while while that's happening you
guys tell me which one is the other
character that
that does
the thing
oh
i forgot
right
does this one have a hunk
anyway you're going the wrong way
dumbass
you've gone the wrong way
my friend you have met a terrible
terrible demise
but uh you know i i don't feel too bad
about it
after all if if it weren't for me it
would have just been from someone else
you know
i guess what i'm trying to say is life
life goes on
well from for everyone else life goes on
not not for you you're you're dead is
this the same one either here nor there
it reminds me of one summer day in the
park this is the same one i was having
just a delightful picnic with my good
friend orville
okay no
oh god oh god
oh you can't get out
oh oh god what's the significance of the
story
i said to him
not every story has to have significance
you know sometimes uh you know sometimes
bail
good old alt f4 coming in
as a friend is there another one
oh yeah it seems that you have met a
horror oh my god demise my friend oh my
god but uh you know these
these things happen in life life goes on
not for you obviously you're you're dead
but uh it reminds me of a time i was i
was having a conversation with my friend
orville
we were uh where were we i think we were
by the
with the the river we were sitting by
the river and watching this just flip
over the falls
and uh i said to orville
you know sometimes i feel like a fish
leaping over and over again it's
different always trying to get somewhere
though i don't know where only to find
myself in the jaws of a beast
he of course looked at me surprised you
know
have you been in the jaws of a beast
friend
to which i said no of course not orville
i said no no no no i i simply meant that
life can seem like a relentless endeavor
to overcome
meaningless obstacles only to meet an
equally meaningless fate regardless of
your efforts regardless of the obstacles
you've passed
and uh orville he he stood and proceeded
to drape me with a picnic cloth to which
i i i asked him i said friend what
what are you doing
he looks at me very concerned really
i feel like you've gotten too much sun
indeed
indeed i had he proceeded to pour me a
glass of just
ice cold lemonade oh you ever mix it
with iced tea you do like little half
lemonade hat oh it's so you should try
it somewhere you can't because you're
dead but anyways so you may be asking
yourself how did i go from sitting by
the falls and drinking lemonade to being
wedged in the air duct not only with
orville but with an entire assortment of
fruity colored friends
well
there's uh there's really no good answer
to that but perhaps i met a demise of my
own at some point and this is my
afterlife or my dream
whatever it might mean i honestly don't
know or
maybe it doesn't mean anything at all
maybe it doesn't mean anything at all
all right all right good good good oh my
god
thank you for rescuing that i'ma look up
uh
look at my some nice secrets there's
probably like a write-up on the wiki or
something like that um i know you guys
are helping me out and i appreciate that
but i also just want to like
double check everything
ultimate custom night okay
so
[Music]
interesting
hold on a moment i'm looking at things
i'm staring at things
i'm staring while i'm uh i'm pulling
this up write in
write in chat in the comments um things
that you know and you want to see that
are secrets in this game and also link
in the description to part two of in
space with markiplier which you are
going to see and also matpat released a
theory
about in space with markiplier that you
should go see and send some love much
love
big love big hearts all the way um leave
a like on that video and leave a like on
in uh part two premiere and be there
monday at noon pacific okay i'm gonna
look at this
okay
oh
interesting
okay
so the thing about old man consequences
okay
so you put old man consequences at one
and then you catch a fish
that's what you do right
that's what you do
yeah thank you mods for putting the link
in the chat there all right so we just
got a
catch a fish
what's that web always there
yeah probably
excuse me
old man consequences
old man
will you
old man
all their consequences
there is a there's entirely a
possibility that he won't appear here
through the entire
forgot about you through the entire time
that we play through this night
uh which is which is so possible it's
very possible
but he's only at one so in the meantime
it gives me a time to review this
wonderful game
look at it all in all of its glory
and all of its grandeur
i mean really honestly it kind of it's
kind of beautiful because it harkens
back to the first game a lot you know
you still got that same sense of like
the office is basically the same the
setup is basically the same it's just so
much more
you know you don't get the same sense of
horror and disturbingness because there
isn't actually like a a
linear story through this but it's still
you know it has a lot of charm i do
appreciate this one it is
nice
i like it a lot
yeah and also i i've seen some people
asking i am fine i just got back from
the hospital like a week ago now i am
100 good if you if you want to find out
how all that went down when uh this
stream ends you can go back beginning i
talked about in the beginning of it yeah
so uh yeah i'm good
i'm good
and for those of you who don't know i
was in the hospital last week but same
thing as usual intestinal blockage
i'm fine
old man consequences where are you
where are you
where are you
no i'm fine
i'm fine
i'm fine
i'm 100 okay
don't worry about me worry about where
old man consequences is
[Music]
i'm
i'm lying
i'm lying about being fine i'm pretty
sure i'm fine i'm pretty sure
fairly certain about that
i just wish old man consequences would
show up
am i in the hospital right now yeah this
isn't live
or i'm live streaming from the hospital
this is a green screen backdrop here
oh there is
hello
what is this
come and sit with me a while
leave the demon to his demons
rest your own soul
there is nothing else
[Music]
is there anything else to do
glitch into the pond
is there some way to get in here
oh
ah there we go
i'm glitching in
wait oh
it crashed well i mean i'm sure that's
supposed to be what happens
yeah okay okay okay okay okay all right
is there a point to that is there a
point
i have no idea is there a point
probably probably
okay
you you player exits by drowning
themselves in the pawn in the same way
as fnaf world which actually caused the
game to crash before we see the gray
people
uh
so apparently this sound
is an extremely slowed down version and
i'm going to turn the volume down for
this
of this
[Music]
[Music]
all right
you know what i i had in this game um
actually that i don't see on this list
um
that's kind of strange
when i
when i opened the game
there was a jump scare
did anyone else see that why is that not
on the list
that's very strange
seriously when i opened the game
it did a jump scare
did anyone else get that
literally before i started streaming i
got that
i think so wait hell let me try to try
to get it again
i thought it would have been rare
jump scares 100 okay cool is it yes
hold on i know the game's closed
trying to see
you never got jump scared in the
beginning there was
i swear
no
you get it first time you that's right
you get it the first time you play
that's what i thought i thought it was
that i thought it was thus
it's fine
right
that's that's what i thought okay so the
next one is golden freddy and then i do
the death coin thing whatever that means
hold on one second it's golden freddy on
one
use death coin on him got it golden
freddy on one
use death coin on him i don't know how
to use the death coin which is the other
problem in this equation
i don't remember
so i need to get coins
buy the death coin
does he approach more if you have a
certain something
that does not want to give me coins
come on
there we go okay
how do i death coin
i'm guessing just when they appear
i think
whoa was that hat always there is a hat
always there
i don't remember that
maybe
oh my god go away
[Music]
thanks
thank you this is definitely what i i
needed right now what did you add how do
i tell what you added
i don't know what you added
i don't know
how do i tell what you added
whatever it's probably fine
this was not there before
oh
s opens the monitor that's super handy
that's extremely handy
huh
and there i go mousing over it again
that's gonna be hard having a break
oh wait god damn it
oh oh
how do i death coin i don't know how to
death coin
how do you death coin
i don't know how do i death coin
i did i did it didn't do it
[Music]
it didn't do it press d no that's not it
oh right with music man there it's not
possible that's what it was
right okay that's what it was
i see i see i see i see music man all
right right that makes sense yeah i
don't like it but it makes sense if you
think about it
okay and then death coin okay now i just
spam this
oh
my god
all right well
all righty then
that's what that is
well that was not very interesting that
was not very interesting at all that was
hardly interesting
hardly
hardly
you know this doesn't say
anything
this doesn't say
um
some say the other easter eggs i know
that there's more
i know there's more there's more right
fredbear is very important
i i'm aware to the lore
of course to the lore
but
what i'm looking at
the vent characters right didn't orville
wasn't orville something about orville i
don't remember
i don't remember at all nad bear
nad bear had voice lines i do remember
that
i do
i do remember that
i do remember that
ned bear
maybe i definitely have the lines come
here ned bear
get over here wrong side here we go
where are you no come here
come here ned bear
come on
silly billy
there we go
come on that bear please
i was just waiting for you to drop your
guard
hmm
oh isn't it like super rare it's rare
isn't it
it is
it's rare
oh
oh no that's fine it's rare
right isn't it
it's rare
i'm looking at some of these things hold
on one second
no no no no
no
i know there's more
does orville have
does he
let's find out let's find out what he's
got
i am going to get back to the actual
like
a game of the game in moon
open it up come on buddy oh he doesn't
get he doesn't get attracted does he no
he does he does he doesn't he doesn't he
just goes wherever he wants
orville please come on buddy oh here you
open her up oh no no you don't want to
go towards the open one oh come on
whatever man come on
let's go ah he's death
come on kill me
i'm here
kill me
kill me
come on
yes yes i'm gonna die yes
yes
death
and
any minute now any minute now
any minute now come on kill me there we
go
i don't get out much so you'll have to
forgive my enthusiasm
ah that's it that's nothing to that
there's nothing to that
there's nothing to it there's nothing to
it i think i think what i'm gonna do is
one second i know that um
this would be an easier way to do this
oh it's kind of it's kind of exists
right i thought it would have been there
hold on
hold on
hold
hold
hold
here we go got it okay
so
is
by
this
characters
that's ned bear stranger danger
[Music]
i was just waiting for you to drop your
guard
whoops that's gonna leave a mark
this is how it feels and you get to
experience it over and over and over
again
forever
i will never let you leave
because in the whole story
of
this particular game
the idea of it is that it is purgatory
right that's the idea it is purgatory
for
is it william afton is it afton is the
afton i really at this point is crazy
that i don't really know
the lore that well
i really don't i i've
just honestly i don't
i wish i did
but unfortunately i don't this is for
some reason people want to pick patch
this big bag i consider it a dignified
death
not really it was actually quite
pathetic
[Music]
[Laughter]
hang on i gotta get in the game i don't
remember that at all i don't remember
that at all
hold on a second wait
i don't remember that at all
i never died a big batch
i never ever died to pick patch that i
love that
come here you
oh is he not lured no he's lured he's
lured he's lureable come on you
come on you
come here
even monkeys fall from trees
[Music]
everything's better with a banjo plan
but
that's uh uh that is that is a goddamn
delight that is a goddamn delight
let me get the other ones if you sit by
the river long enough
you will see the body of your enemy
float by
[Music]
[Laughter]
the nail that sticks out gets hammered
down
the talented hawk hides his claws
i just love it i love that
i think that's so funny
god this hilarious oh i've got a knock
on the door
is that what i think it is
okay i'll be right out to get it oh
all right one second don't mind me
hold on
wait for it
i got a delivery
i got a delivery
yeah i got some lunch because if you if
you haven't figured it out i'm going to
be here for a while because i want
there's a lot to pour through here but
also just like i want to uh
i don't know
two days until part two comes out two
days can you believe that two days
man all right so uh while that's
happening let me go pull up you guys
want happy frog
let's see what happens let's just uh
[Music]
let's just give a little death to happy
frog to make it official
let's see what happens
and this way i can enjoy my food
oh yeah for some reason i thought it was
going to happen instantaneously
i'll give it some time let's see what
happens here
hello
please
kill me
there we go
now we're getting it
[Music]
no no no no no no come back don't run
away i know how much you left
i bet you weren't expecting me where are
you turn your back for one second and
i'm like was you ninja skills
okay
i can see why you like that
i can see why you like that
the adorably sickeningly cute i get it
i see what's going on here
also i'm farming up those things which
is awfully nice
let me go back um
let me look for what is a happy frog
is that the name
happy frog
happy
frog um
oh wait this is the wrong place oh god
where is it
hold on here
bam
okay you and i don't get to talk as
often as i'd like
all right you and i don't get to
everyone underestimates me but then they
turn their back and i'm like boo and
they're like
[Music]
move over freddy fazbear happy frog is
the new star of the show
we've only just begun i will never let
you leave i will never let you rest
i didn't know there was one of those
there
we've only just begun
i will never let you leave i will never
let you rest
all right
that's fascinating
thank you for that
um
appreciate it
okay so
let me look up um
uh uh
orville
orville elephant audio
what did you think of my act
i don't get out much i hope you enjoyed
the garage oh
here we go
he tried to release you
he tried to release us
but i'm not gonna let that happen
i will hold you here
i will keep you here
no matter how many times
they burn us
so it is some kind of a purgatory
that's the idea behind it right it is a
purgatory
he tried to really try to release you
he tried to release us
but i'm not gonna let that happen
i will hold you here
i will keep you here
no matter how many times
they burn us
so that's in reference to pizzeria
simulator because the end of that one
when you actually beat it unlike i did
in my revisited i did way back in the
day
it all burns to the ground right
that's the whole concept it burns
that's the idea behind it
but someone is not letting that happen
and i know that there's some kind of
like digital connection with the vr game
like something about how
because
they're trying to keep punishing and
maybe it's like a vicious cycle of like
endless punishment which means you just
never escape from it in the first place
uh you have this scenario where you've
created an even greater evil by trying
to punish the evil that was before and
in doing so make an even bigger monster
it's like the cycle of hatred
perpetuates or some crap like that you
know what i mean
fun time foxy is funtime foxy got some
stuff
fun time foxy
uh
let's see
oh whoops that's not the right page fun
time
funtime proxy audio here we go
custom night all right no that's the
sound here we go
it seems you couldn't make it to my show
so i brought the show to you
there's there's not there's nothing lore
wise here is there show times are on the
hour
that's just hurting for the eardrums
you guys are just jerks
i know it's loud
it's very loud all right is there any
other uh
jacko chica
okay
all right
i am a burning reminder of your misdeeds
hmm
come and burn with me
the fire within me burns the turtle and
now you shall as well
greetings from the fire and from the one
you should not have killed
the one you should not have killed i'm
kind of guessing that you should not
have killed anybody but
that's probably someone important right
the one that should not have killed
okay who else
what am i eating i'm eating lunch that
was uh that was um
fiery chica
regular cheek audio
withered bonnie
um let's see
okay withered bonnie audio
hmm i'm not seeing that one withered
bonnie
withered bonnie i'm only seeing one
withered bonnie hang on one second let
me look at this chica audio
uh
ultimate custom knight i never thought
there's the reference again to the one
you shouldn't have killed
he's eating once it's okay yeah i'm i
need to eat i do i promise okay this is
um toy chica though where's my beak
lodged in your forehead of course
let's go somewhere more private
so i can eat you
that's awful okay well that was not
worth my time
that's right and don't you come back now
you're here
it's apparently rockstar chica that'll
teach you for trying to trick this old
bird
thought you could fool me with that sign
but i was too smart for you
i may not like wet floors but the smell
of fresh meat is just
whoops looks like you're the one that
slipped up this time uh-huh anyway lefty
right no left lefty
lefty audio that's another one of the
weird ones
oh
is lefty the one you should not have
killed is that the idea here
i've been looking for you
and now i will never let you go
shhh
i'm so glad that i found you
let me make room for you
it will all be over soon
ah golden freddy is the one you should
not have killed i see there's probably a
quite a few lore videos from matpat
about that
okay good
rock star bonnie
and well there better be something good
yeah cause i'm not seeing um oh wait
withered bonnie
no that's different bonnie audio
oh here we go
[Music]
[Music]
see you stark
i didn't know that i was stalking you
all right interesting
uh who else was i looking for
right rock star bonnie audio
[Music]
okay all right oh there's some we
already did mr hippo unless there's
another mr hoppo out there i don't think
that there's anything more about mr
hippo
all right and i'll look it up if there
is another story i'm not even gonna play
it i'm just gonna know for myself
good god
oh my god
there's four
there's four of them
oh my gosh four of them
i'm not gonna play it i'm not gonna play
i'm not gonna play it
i'm not gonna play it
i'm not gonna play it
i'm not gonna do it okay here's
nightmare freddy
i am remade but not by you
by the one you should not have killed
there we go that's the one you should
not have killed apparently good good
good now
no light can save you now
i'm not gonna play it
i'm not gonna play it i'm not even gonna
do a poll i have always been hiding in
your shadow
what a gift to relish
a victim
do you really want it
you really want it
so what you really want
i'll do it
i'll do it i'll do it
give me a chance to eat my food i'll do
it
all right but but you guys got to tell
me which one is the new one because i
really have no clue
how would i know
you know what i mean
you asked for this
my friend you have met a terrible
terrible demise
but uh you know i i don't feel too bad
about it
after all if if it weren't for me it
would have just been no we've heard this
one out we've heard that one
definitely have heard that one before
uh it seems that you have met your end
oh what a pity
you know i i don't feel too bad about it
though
after all if it weren't me
it would have just been one of the
others i guess
i'm honestly just glad to be out of
those air ducts you know it's it's not
easy for a hippopotamus to fit up there
and not easy to get down either
not as young as i used to we heard this
one no no no no no they don't all start
like that it's not identical it's not
identical
it seems that you have met a horrible
demise my friend but uh you know these
these things happen in in life life goes
on
not for you obviously you're you're dead
but uh it reminds me of a time i was i
was having a conversation with my friend
orville
we were uh where were we i think we were
by the
with the river we were sitting by the
river and watching the fish leap over
the falls
and uh i said to orville
you know sometimes i feel like a fish
leaping over and over again always
trying to get somewhere we did we
there's one we did it we did that one
got the one about the fish
my friend you have met a terrible
terrible demise
but uh you know i i don't feel too bad
about it
after all if if it weren't for me it
would have just been from someone else
you know
i guess what i'm trying to say is life
life goes on
well from for everyone else life goes on
not not for you you're you're dead
but that's neither here nor there
it reminds me of one summer day in the
park i was having just a delightful
picnic with my good friend orville and i
said to him i said orville i
i have a story and he said to me what's
the significance of the story and
i i think we've seen that one
my friend you have met a terrible
terrible demise
but uh you know i i don't feel too bad
about it no
we've gotten terrible terrible demise
we've gotten horrible time friend you
have met a terrible terrible demise no
no no but uh you know i i don't feel
yeah i i have the the transcripts of it
in front of me at the moment so that
we're looking we did
terrible terrible demise
have met your end
your journey has ended and horrible
demise those are the different ones
we've done horrible
demise we've done terrible terrible
demise we've done
we need journey has ended
journey has ended that's what we're
looking for journey
has ended
hey it's
oh god oh god what mys my friend but uh
you know these these no that's not it
that's not it that's not it no
journey has ended
ah it seems that you have met your end
oh what a pity no journey ended
my friend you have met a terrible
terrible democrat no journey
there is
well
uh it seems that your journey has ended
very sorry about that it was was always
going to end this way of course
if it weren't by me it would have just
been by some other you know terrible
thing just you could not imagine how
terrible it would be
just i get scared thinking about it i'm
glad it's not me it reminds me of a of a
time i was speaking to my good friend
orville we were
we were sitting on a park bench watching
the pigeons i was on the left he was on
the wait was i on the right or left
anyways it doesn't matter we were
sitting on there watching the pigeons
and i i said to orville friend those
birds are frozen and he kind of looked
at me like i lost my mind but i reminded
him that it was winter you know and
often birds will sit in a tree until
they freeze
and then they they you know sort of fall
to the ground until the sun warms up and
they can you know move around again so i
said to orville you might as well save
those breadcrumbs until the birds thaw
because they can't very well enjoy them
in the condition they're in to which he
asked what i meant and
asking what condition the crumbs should
be and before he threw them to the birds
assuming that i meant the birds couldn't
enjoy the breadcrumbs in the condition
that the crumbs were in when in fact i
had meant the birds could not enjoy them
in the condition that the birds were in
considering that the birds were frozen
you know so he took a moment and then
threw his last handful onto the ground i
said to him orville why did you throw
the bread crumbs to the birds when i
just told you they're frozen
to which he responded the bread crumbs
are not frozen again misunderstanding my
words i didn't mean to say that the
bread crumbs were frozen when i said i
told you they're frozen i'd been
referring to the birds
you know in hindsight what i should have
said was and this would make perfect
sense why did you throw the bread crumbs
to the birds when the birds are frozen
he misunderstood upon my correction
stating that he didn't know what else to
do with the breadcrumbs and that perhaps
you know when the birds thawed they'd
still be able to eat the crumbs so i i
said to orville i said this is what i
said to him i said orville the birds may
be dead
sorry my mech was low
all right
so i'm still eating lunch but what i
want to do right now
what i want to do right now is i want to
see
someone beat 50 20 mode
uh now you guys can suggest which person
to do it um i know there's a couple
people apply plenty of people that have
beaten 20 mode but i want to know
who we should watch beat it
in its entirety
to learn
dark oh okay all right seems to be the
popular suggestion
so let's give that
british bastard
let's give that guy some
sweet delicious views one second let me
open this up here
because i have some food that i need to
eat
and then i need to
get that underway also reminder in the
link in the description is the link to
the premiere page of part two of in
space with markiplier which is
premiering this monday in less than two
days in like 47 hours you're gonna see
that set a reminder on it so that you
can join and we can all watch live
together if you've never done a premiere
it's very fun ask anybody that was there
in the last one it's very fun we can all
watch it together and then you can play
it all you want
all right
where is this
okay
i think this is the one we did it
i think i think this is it this might be
it
okay hold on here hold on
um actually
before
before i do this
i need to go to the bathroom
so what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to
i am going to
do something here that you're just gonna
love
i call this um
i call this picture in picture
delightfulness uh
one second here
delightful picture in picture-ness
you guys get to see
all the lovely people
who are over
on the premiere page dedicated it's
actually stunning how many people just
camp out in the premiere page um but i
need to go to the restroom so you guys
can see this
and then i am going to
go to the bathroom while this plays and
then i'll be right back so have fun
watching yourselves i guess link in the
description for that i'll be right back
[Music]
through
the night
and wake me
[Music]
my bed
[Music]
[Music]
and one
takes my soul
away
i'm back
i'm back
hold on
hold on
i'm here i swear
i'm here
hello you guys having fun
you guys having fun good glad you're
enjoying yourselves here
all right
next up
on the docket
is doco
who we are gonna watch
as they
show us how it's done
with
50 20 mode in ultimate custom night
my palms are sweaty mom's spaghetti i
don't know why
oh my god wait hold on
hang on one second i have to pause this
what is happening
hold on
look at
the ridiculousness of this moment here
you see bonnie here is actually in front
of these papers how does that make any
sense what is going on here what is the
lay the
let me flip my camera over to the other
side as well because i'm blocking some
of this not that you can actually make
any sense out of any of this
what
is happening
okay
i'm just gonna
let me just
join no taco here there we go okay so
let me actually back up a bit
because i believe that this is the way
that you
uh fight this
this is like the first time you beat it
so there's probably like some
some glitching of the game i believe if
i'm not mistaken
anyway
thank you for depositing five
[Music]
please deposit five points
thank you for depositing five points
oh yeah wait no sorry
yeah guys
this is me
ish me
doco
here playing
yeah i'm doing it guys
i'm gonna win
i mean i'm gonna win
so what i'm seeing here
what i'm seeing here is
this is not the original one that he did
is this not the original
yeah i'm doing it guys collaboratively
i've got the mouse taco's got the
keyboard we're a team right buddy high
five oh he's busy
he can't hide by me right now but anyway
we're a team
this is a collective win
so
what the [ __ ] is that
what does the legs do
what's with the legs
wait
i
i don't understand any of this
oh that's me
please thank you for demonstrating five
coins
me
oh
[Applause]
teamwork
oh my god we did it buddy
[Music]
i know right yeah
[Applause]
look at that scarf
baby
[Music]
boy oh it's okay don't cry
don't cry we did it
you and me pal you and me hey you know
what i'll even give you most of the
credit i know it was actually 50 50 but
you deserve more oh you split 60 40
credit your way
oh god guys i know
oh man
what a team effort what a team effort
[Music]
me too many
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
anyway he had to go
daco had to go
doco had to leave it's weird all right
so i didn't learn
anything from that
yeah you know he was he was uh
inconsolable so he had to
he had to go
anywho
all right so
um i think
uh this someone else
because i didn't learn
anything from that
i literally did not learn anything
what is this 50 40 mode that doesn't
even make any sense
40.
okay here we go here's here's a video
explaining
uh
of
50 20 mode the actual like mechanics of
it
oh dj surf has one well there's i'm
gonna give some love to taco i mean no
not love to
dj surf of course
oh
i'm back to normal videos and
like i said in the live stream when we
beat 50 20 mode i am going to be doing
some theory videos and then i've got to
read this baby
oh god
and then we'll just continue doing
normal videos like we always do um so
before i wanted to go on to the theories
though and when when i posted my 50 20
video of the reaction and stuff a lot of
people were asking if i could do a
tutorial on how to beat 50 20 mode so
far i do want um it's pretty simple
um in my brain but it's actually very
difficult to talk about through doing it
and then
like doing it while talking it's really
hard so and then i'll watch my video
and pause the video and say i did this
and this and this
and just see if it makes sense to any of
you guys please remember that this run
of 50 20 mode is very look based when
you have got the practice involved with
it
you can be great at this you could be
amazing and it's very easy to learn i
promise you guys the the the start of
this is very easy to learn it's just you
can get really unlucky with a lot of
things mainly toy freddy rockstar bonnie
and
uh foxy okay that's basically it
and all of the other animatronics are
very easy to deal with very easy to deal
with and
um if you haven't seen the run
you guys will probably know what's going
to happen and the main thing that you've
got to look out for is your power okay
if you look at the end of my run i had
one percent power left and others run
out of power just before the end and
and that's you're gonna that's gonna be
your issue but the best way to do this
is to keep switching between the power
generator and the fan to the fat off to
the global music box the global music
box is your best friend in this because
it looks after chica from jump scaring
you and of course it looks after the
puppet and that will get some time to
get used to also
power up to your best friend frigid
because it starts at 50 degrees free
fast coins it's really good and 2 extra
battery dd repel does not work in 50 20
mode guys don't bother wasting it okay
dd is indestructible in 50 20 mode she
will spawn whether you have it on or not
so just ignore that so keep your power
ups open if you've practiced before 50
20 mode you should be okay with this run
guys okay and remember that you have to
buy the def coin to get rid of funtime
foxy use the defcoin on funtime foxy
okay guys so here is my run uh nice and
simple okay guys it's gonna be really
quick but this will be like i can pause
the video and talk about things so that
i think we should have done this first
really
so as you can see what i'd usually do
and i'll say it again uh turn off the
fan and put the power generator on or
you can leave the fan on if you want to
it's totally up to you click on the wet
floor sign to remove it
and then as soon as you go on the camera
guys press f to get rid of balloon boy
or jj getting in the office and then
open it again
you'll be safe okay
um i quickly switched to the duct system
put the uh position of the audio law
camera cam eight shut off uh mr hugs
get some fast coins on the way which
really does help i went straight on to
the um the prize corner went straight
off the monitor okay
put on the mask just in case of golden
freddy
guys shut there because fredbear was
there again more fuzz coins really good
way to just get fast coins if the
animatronics spawn straight away it's
really helpful
okay
then i do the cycle lift up the camera
shut the vent lift up the camera shut
the vents
obviously there's more problems as well
i've made a mistake here uh with bb but
it's totally fine don't need to worry
about it
i actually need to pause this because i
was so busy goofing i didn't actually
take in anything of that what he said
so i need hang on i need to actually go
back what the hell did he just say any
of it
it's actually really quick but this will
be like i can pause the video and talk
about things so that i think we should
have done this first really
so as you can see what i'd usually do
and i'll say it again uh turn off the
fan and put the
okay power generator on
so
turning off the fan
and then amazingly
you turn on or off the fan power
generator
for 10 seconds then switch to music box
and i'm curious about that is that just
for the sake of getting rid of
the need to go wind up the music box i
i'm just kind of curious what that's for
specifically right
i'm sure he explains it but you know i'm
just asking questions or you can leave
the fan on if you want to it's totally
up to you click on the wet floor sign to
remove it
and then as soon as you go on the camera
guys press f to get rid of balloon boy
or jj getting in the office and then
open it again
you'll be safe okay
um i quickly switched to the duct system
right
okay so that makes sense so if you just
keep that audio lure there they cannot
go anywhere put the uh position of the
audio law
camera cam eight shut off uh mr hugs
get some fast coins on the way which
really does help i went straight onto
the um the prize corner went straight
off the monitor okay
but on the mask just in case of golden
freddy guys shut there because fredbear
was there
okay
what's the music box around 10 to
check
timer
so in all honesty what is doing is
trying to eliminate as many variables as
possible
you're throwing blanket sweep things
to try
to make this
work correct
that's basically the idea
i think
again more fuzz coins really good why
did you just get fast coins if
the animatronics spawn straight away
wait what how do you get fast coins what
are you talking about more fast on the
mask just in case of golden freddy
guys shut there because fredbear was
there again more fuzz coins really good
way to just get fast coins if the
animatronics spawn straight away
what
how do you
what do you
what do you mean
what are you talking about went straight
off the monitor okay
put on the mask just in case of golden
freddy
guys shut there because fredbear was
there again more fast coins
you get fast coins for shutting the door
on nightmare
if they knock on the door you get a
really
i did not know that
i did not know that really good way to
just get fast coins if the animatronics
spawn straight away it's really helpful
okay
then i do the cycle lift up the camera
shut the vent lift up the camera shut
the vents
obviously there's more problems as well
i've made a mistake here uh with bb but
it's totally fine don't need to worry
about it
there we go one more fast coin and we
should be good but balloon boys in the
way
so
up and down again shut the vent got ten
fast coins okay shut all the doors put
the heater on for a little bit put the
music box back on
why the heat
why the heater
okay now i go to the uh the price corner
remember guys left middle door shut
including bbs uh you don't need to shut
bb's door when you quickly go up and
back down because he doesn't have time
to get into the office and neither does
jj so i've got ten fast coins guys the
second challenger has appeared like i
said
didn't he just say that the cycle was
you open the camera you close the side
vent and then you
you ff to open that down but this one
you don't but he has awf here
and that is plushtrap
quickly by i've reset the vent as well
that's really good reset that
and then there's plush trap okay so it's
a two birds with one stone i def coin
fun time foxy as well as watching plus
strap plus trap goes then i go straight
to cam two turn off turn
okay so that makes sense with the
deathcoin effects
funtime foxy because that would be the
problem getting at funtime foxy on the
right hour because you number one have
to check first number two you have to
make sure that you can get there in the
first place which would be difficult to
do when everything else is going chaos
chaos
so
then just by staring at uh trap plush
strap goes away okay
got that
down the monitor i put my mask on just
in case of golden freddy and we are now
happy we are completely fine now and
safe well i'd say safe
okay no the next animatronic is
nightmare chica to get rid of nightmare
chica guys it's really easy and also
very helpful as well because it cools
down your office use the ac
the cooler that makes the jaws go back
up and she will get eradicated here's a
very cool tip as well if you know
nightmare cheek is about to come just
turn on the cooler ready for her she
will never appear on the screen because
you've just used the cooler as soon as
you spawned and she's gone okay remember
that
but i have to wait a little bit longer
easy peasy and also guys ah right
you're you're totally right about that i
forgot that some of the animatronics in
the vents are not affected by the heater
i did forget about that you're right the
ones that wouldn't be affected by the
lure would then be affected by the
heater that makes sense and also the
heater affects this dude here
um
if you have a cool temperature just use
the heater on rockstar freddie and
i've noticed if you even like tap the
keta and then go back onto something
else eventually rockstar freddy will
just go off anyway
even without using the heater oh you
don't need to keep it on the whole time
for ah that makes sense and so yeah
um this is basically just chill time now
as you can see though guys foxy is on
the desk so i shut the left and middle
door risk it lift up the camera back
down and bonnie does spawn on the table
you cannot you can you can't see him but
bonnie's there if you do have foxy on
the table wait about six seconds guys
and then lift the monitor back up but
remember to shut the middle and left
doors before you do that and always use
the heater before you do that too switch
back to the music box up down and bonnie
should appear on the table okay if we
have them if we have bonnie on the table
guys that means foxy's not gonna move or
anything okay so that's great but like i
said it's inevitable that foxy will
eventually get into the office but you
should be okay guys you should be a okay
because when foxy does get into the
office if you quickly switch back uh to
bonnie on the table foxy can't progress
to kill you so having bonnie on the
table is 100
a must okay and foxy will troll you at
some point in your runs he will always
troll you because that's what sadly what
fox is like for example he's in the
office now with his legs and his body
but he can't make any more progress to
kill me because bonnie's on the table
as you can see
now fox is on the table again if i
quickly lift up again and again foxy's
moved a little bit more but foxy is
still on the table annoyingly so
i'm surprised i'm not dead
wow okay that's really lucky
that's what i mean guys you can get
lucky with foxy foxy still didn't attack
me and bonnie's now on the table so
that's really good okay the next
challenges are the minority okay so that
was a lot of information to say a few
simple things there just like the
mechanics of how foxy works
um and what you need to do in terms of
like what i noticed in his actual
playthrough of this is that he's not
lifting the camera very much right so
he's not engaging a lot of the
animatronics that are based in the
camera so a lot of what i did when i did
like 520 is like i was trying to beat
everything's mechanic like head-to-head
right this is a strategy to eliminate as
many variables as possible and eliminate
the
chance that certain animatronics are
going to kill you
right makes sense
venus that cover your screen for about
45 seconds and as you can see here
bonnets here just click on a nose and
she'll go away just like sister location
custom night really nice and simple the
problem with and bonnet though is
sometimes night marion's lurking there
and it can be really annoying i've died
a few times to that or also remember
guys the min arenas are really annoying
with night marion again you can't see
nightmare on sometimes so always put
your mouse at the left side of the
screen always if you don't put your
monitor at the left side of the screen
you might die because the left side of
the screen like the bottom left um is to
save so night marion does not spawn
there and always make sure to check out
for nightmare bb as well because you as
you can see through the gaps and
everything the nooks and crannies
nightmare bb is currently standing up
and active just flash him and he'll go
away yeah no he's he's not wrong about
that that is hard to see
that is that is so weird
it's just this tiny tiny tiny window
to see that and actually i can see that
nightmare uh freddy is starting to
pop in here too
this is just like this is awful this is
the worst why would they do this there's
got to be a way to get rid of those
things right or maybe not
but yeah that's a tiny thing to see but
but the good thing is with what he's
talking about is like the less the
monitor is up
the less risk factor you have if you're
not flipping up and down non-stop then
you run less of a risk of
causing that to kill you right because a
lot of these things a lot of these
animatronics are based on a system where
if you enact change say you flip the
monitor
that is the only way that they can
actually instigate an attack some
animatronics
not all obviously some of them just like
do whatever they want whenever they want
but a lot of these things work on a
dependency of change right you have to
change the scene you have to flip up the
camera you have to switch cameras stuff
like that you know what i mean okay as
you know already
okay
so yeah that's basically it guys we can
just chill remember though to keep
switching between the power generator
and the fan to the global music box okay
that's really really important um like i
said so
basically keeping
from the very beginning of the game the
the whole concept is keep the global
music box going
because there is no time to go wind the
thing
i am curious how he deals with toy
freddy
how does toy freddy get dealt with at
the start of the run i had the power
generator on for about 10 seconds 10 to
15 seconds
and then i switched to the music box
it's about 15 seconds for chica to get
angry and the puppet about 15 seconds
too so always switch to the music box
and and keep you you'll learn it
yourself guys just keep switching and
between the power generator and the
music box because if you don't have the
music box on you'll die
right that makes total sense that makes
total sense i get that maybe there's
other animatronics that are
like affected by the music box and going
to the power generator makes sense too
um
i don't know if his fans going right now
because that would just be like keeping
power in there um and i guess you would
just listen for music man because that's
the only one that really kills you from
noise
so yeah i've got everything on at the
moment the power generator on with the
fan for about 10 seconds
turned it off switch to the uh music box
next up is lol bit that's the next
challenger all you need to do is type
lol on the keyboard it's very easy it
doesn't cause any interruptions you can
still play while this is on
and just type lol as you if you watch me
i just willingly willing
willingly
whatever you say and just um
do this
easy gone forever okay
now as you can see the ventilation error
is coming up and we only check on that
literally last minute because we don't
want to go on the cameras at all guys
okay
we want to avoid the cameras as much as
possible i reset it but i quickly shut
the left and middle door always remember
that and always remember to use the
heater for like literally
three seconds before you go on it okay
because you'll get jump scared by the
vent duct animatronics
right ah
okay so the reason that must be is that
the animatronics in the vent are again
change based right so the the
animatronics can be all the way up to
the end of the vent but they cannot
actually kill you until you do something
to instigate a change like put up the
monitor so the reason he says put the
heater on is to
push them back the ones that are not
affected by the audio lure which is in
place
you shove those back
and then you shift you you you do the
left and
front
vents because the the ones in the vents
in the front the top of the ceiling must
also be the same in that they are change
based
where you can only pop up the monitor
to die and by shutting that before you
do it
you don't die similarly a lot of the
animatronics say like regular five
nights at freddy's won freddy fazbear in
the left only kills you because it's
change based this is what i'm imagining
these things are about
okay
keeping the left door shut and the
middle vent short keeps rockstar chica
and freddy from the left door getting
you and the vent animatronics from
getting in such as all of them and a
mangle and with a chi cam okay
so they only get in when you're on the
monitor but if you've got the door shut
they can't get in okay
and that's basically it for the most
part guys i keep lifting up the monitor
going back down i did that guys because
foxy was on the table
um and now bonnie's on the tables that's
good that's what we want never have foxy
on the table guys like i said bonnie
needs to be on the table for you to
progress
like i said though foxy will eventually
get into the office always also here's a
tip guys if you've got a second spare
keyboard and you're not using it and
you've got no purpose of it just use it
um on below your desk and
take out all the keys apart from see and
enter and you can use your feet and to
get rid of old man consequences and l
chips adverts it's really easy and
really
really
it's it's
i
love that
i love that as a concept that you would
have to do to be able to beat some of
those other things so you don't have to
press c and enter is very far away
however
i would also say
you can simply bind that to your mouse
buttons
and then you can click those however
they also doesn't
the stream deck
foot pedal that they make now that you
could bind probably to separate keys i
do love that about the spare keyboard
thing ripping out every
rip out every button except for see and
enter that is such a crazy suggestion
that would actually work but it's such
an extreme thing to jump to i love
that that's where his mind went it's
great
do i respect that
big respect
anyway it's easy to do because you won't
get distracted then uh with your hands
and fingers and you know it's two two
birds with one stone then and that's
basically it guys when you've done the
first part you just pray that toy
freddie doesn't jump scare you or you'd
make a mistake okay
um
you are going to have some issues at
some points where toy freddy jump scares
you were like 4am or 5am but that's just
that's just look guys you've just got to
get lucky with toy threading
and keep remembering to switch between
the power generator and the global music
box okay
so as you can see again guys the
ventilation's about to go so what i do
is use the heater and you can hear them
like tapping when you've got the heater
on that's them backing away okay
and then switch to the global music box
reset i had the i did shut those doors
then very quickly it's just in your
system you get really quick at shutting
doors and going on the cameras
so i noticed that the uh the the
marionettes are gone right okay
and then switch to the global music box
reset i had the i did shut the door and
foxy should be on the table
so that's fascinating they they do fade
after a while
hey okay what caused it and then
switched the global music box reset i
had the
that is interesting
to me that is interesting to me because
i don't i don't remember him saying
anything
about why that did that
do they just fade after a while no
matter what
they disappear after an hour oh okay
well that's not bad oh he did say that i
must have missed it i did shut those
doors then very quickly it's just in
your system you get really quick at
shutting doors and going on the cameras
and foxy should be on the table that's
bad
so we have to wait a little bit because
you know the captain
that's them backing away people before
okay
look those doors then switch to the
global music box reset i had the i did
he didn't see the table until he had the
mask lifted because he needed to lift
the mask so it's when you come back from
going to the vent not only is okay so
the pattern is like you turn the heater
on you you close left and front doors uh
open the thing click the ventilation
drop it put the mask on immediately go
to the left
and maybe if you see nightmare on the
way and foxy should be on the table
that's bad
so we have to wait a little bit because
toy chica caused a problem up and down
bonnie's on the table nice and easy it
doesn't matter about bb or j
bb is not really a problem
and it's just jj jj is a bigger issue
because of the doors
um if phoebe does get into your office
make sure to shut the middle vent um if
phantom freddie's about to jump scare
you because if phantom freddie jump
scares you and you've got the vent open
that allows the vent animatronics to get
inside so if he's about to jump scare
you and you can't flash him should the
middle vent and you'll be okay for the
rest of the run you will have no issues
at all like i said foxy will eventually
get into the office and if he does just
lift up the camera again and back down
and just hope that bonnie gets onto the
table because foxy can't progress unless
fox is on the table okay it's as simple
as that okay
and when you're at about 5am guys um
you're in the all clear basically when
you're when you're at about five a.m
this will be my last ventilation thing
and bonnie's on the table
so i use the heater shut both doors up
and down done
that's it
the run is over now guys i do not need
to check the camera ever again so i know
that it's over now okay foxy can't kill
me because i'm not going to lift up the
power generate i'm not going to lift up
the monitor
now all you need to do at the last brief
moment is keep switching between the
power generator and the music box that's
it and keep your mouse at the left side
you don't want to die by night marion at
5am
and that's basically it guys and
what you'll see you can see it flashing
here guys use the vent use the vent uh
system don't do it do not do it you
don't need to
and there you go
so
the only other question that i have is
in the beginning of this did
he
at any point need to
address like the plush
animatronics
pressure
right is this it okay
put on the mask just in case of golden
freddy
guys shut there because fredbear was
there again more fuzz coins really good
way to just get fast coins if the
animatronics spawn straight away it's
really helpful
okay
then i do the cycle lift up the camera
shut the vent lift up the camera shut
the vents
obviously there's more problems as well
i've made a mistake here
so you even made a mistake by not
closing that side vent and letting
balloon boy in there which could have
been a coin or obviously could have been
like not having the uh
the flashlight be disabled which is
obviously a problem
so uh with bb but all the doors put the
heat though
up and down again so a little bit boys
left middle doors shut including bbs
yeah so the problem is they cost 20
coins on the hardest difficulty okay
so you're he's not buying that ever
so what
causes
that to never be a problem
you know if you stay on cam 2 they don't
kill interesting okay that's why he said
stay on cam 2 and okay that makes sense
because
i i still don't know how um
toy
freddy is taking care of maybe toy
freddy doesn't kill you if say for
example
you have like
the
the
the door closed on the left
that might be cam stalling yeah
foot equals no issues
yeah
okay okay
okay okay
okay
okay
okay
so
this is good knowledge this is great
knowledge actually this is fantastic
knowledge
i totally believe that beating this is
doable
now what i want to watch is
is it
uh
i want to see
hold on everybody hold on
hold the phone
one second
okay this is good so this is another
person that has beaten 50 20 mode right
this is i believe this is dj sturf
who has also been knit this is a video
where
there's the toby eye tracker involved so
i can actually see where he's looking
which should be interesting
one million combo
hey what's up everyone dj sturf here and
i have something here that i think
you'll find interesting it is the
toby eye tracker five all right so i got
an i get it i get it i get it i get it
for that
and then mr coke one replied no idea but
still food for thought
food for thought indeed thanks mr coke
one all right here we go with 50 20 mode
with the tobii eye tracker 5
it's like the stupidest intro ever so
anyway enjoy
please deposit
for depositing five coins
hey
please deposit five coins
please deposit five coins
please deposit five coins
please deposit five coins
please deposit please deposit five
points
thank you for depositing five coins
[Music]
so what i'm noticing that's a little bit
different from the it's not too terribly
different right
there was a lot more activity happening
in the first two minutes of this than
there was in the other one this is a
more recent
version i would say
of a 50 20 win
and
it's fascinating because
one of the distinct differences i
noticed is that he's not using the
heater because if he was
then
this would be dealt with with the coins
asking for the coins he's actually
physically depositing the coins which i
find to be fascinating i don't remember
the last time that he popped up the
camera because he hasn't in a while so
that's still part of the same strategy
generally
let me see if i can find this so yeah
this is strange he actually did
set this up i don't know if doco did as
well
but he actually did set this up here
so that it could be
taken care of basically which i think is
like
that's fascinating that's fascinating
anyway i'm gonna keep i'm gonna keep
watching on this okay so foxy's in so he
wasn't paying attention to fine
he did okay so doco did so this might be
a similar
pretty similar
okay
[Music]
i guess if you have it anyway it's less
of a risk because then you don't have to
worry about switching from the heater
because you do have time for that coin
you don't really need to i guess
and maybe minimizing the use of the
heater is like
minimizing the temperature gain and then
you don't have to worry so much about
putting the air conditioner on maybe
it's a more reliable power system
because he does seem to have a lot more
power than doco did at the time i'm just
gonna take the risk right why not
because he's got a minute left to go and
he's still got 38 power that shows me
that a less utilization of the heater is
actually being more beneficial
because less heat means less
work
less nonsense
and i think it still is up to rng about
getting that bonnie
switch right
now i'm pretty sure that he doesn't have
to open the camera again right
well at least that's an eye tracker you
can see what i'm looking at
pretty close and he does use his fan
versus the ac so that's what i see in my
periphery as opposed to like full on me
looking at something i'm guessing what
he does
i'm guessing what he does is probably he
utilizes more of the desk fan plus the
power generator um i was i wasn't paying
attention exactly to what was on at the
time
yeah general 5020 strategy does not even
use the heater which which makes sense
to me um
the only time you would use the heater
is to push back animatronics or in the
vent that are about to kill you and the
only time that you would do that is when
you were opening the vent
because why not if you're getting coins
from getting those things anyway and
you've got things locked when you're
because you're on camera too and you
don't sit away from that so so really
it's just the opening phase of trying to
set up so that toy freddy
has a thing
huh
fascinating
not bad 25
yeah
25 that was good
okay so that's the tobii eye tracker
five
interesting
okay
all right fascinating
i'm kind of curious
there's
it doesn't all right i'm not gonna say
it doesn't seem as hard because
definitely it's difficult right but i
remember when i was on matt pat's live
stream this guy dj surf was also on the
live stream and i watched him beat it
live on like his second or third try
it did not take that many strides and
don't get me wrong what he's doing is
very skillful he's really got this down
to a science but that shows me that it's
not as heavily rng based as it seemed
previously
so technically
it should work
right
right
right
okay
interesting
interesting
interesting
interesting
but the question is i'm trying to
understand how
much time it would take me to learn all
these things that need to be learned to
be able to do them i actually
i want to see something
this is going to be
very strange
okay
this could be a little strange um
i want to look at something because i
haven't seen it in a bit
it's an old
there's a small youtuber that needs to
uh get some attention definitely
i just want to see
what this other youtuber
did this strange bizarre youtuber
did
originally
so long ago
in this endeavor right that's all i want
to see
i'm going to give it just a couple more
tries because this is this is obviously
not going to happen oh wait no this is
post that i want to see um
what i was doing
well i guess i'll just sit here then
well
you know this is fun
right okay
not that
not that
ah there we go okay
ah there you go
there we go
oh what am i doing
ah god my brain my brain
my brain but
from what i was seeing there it's
nearly impossible but i don't
okay that was me prank 20
i'm losing it already i'm complete no no
no no
thing
is pretty much out
but with so many
is that a new record 23 nah 20
yeah
hold on hold on hold on
where the hell is i know i did this at
some point
where i actually played i i didn't do 20
50 20 mode i did uh 50 eyes it's not
going to look
that's what the hardest i did was
what am i doing i have no idea what is
this other strange youtuber doing here
we go this is what i was looking for i
just wanted to see
because i in my entire time playing this
i never looked up any other person's
strategy in terms of playing i was just
trying to beat this on my own just the
way i wanted to beat it
with uh 55 mode you want to see this
so i'm winding the music box obviously
they don't do that
i'm worrying about funtime foxy
obviously they don't do that
4 a.m
i don't even have my
audio lure in the correct place i don't
think
i'm looking over to the right which is
like why would i need
i'm moving i'm closing doors in the
background
which is correct but i'm doing it more
times than i need to
i'm also buying all of these things
because i'm flipping cameras
in a sense i'm making this a lot harder
than it needs to be which was the idea
because i like that um but also like it
won't work for 50 20 mode
every hour on the hour
oops i had that thing left open there
here we go
4 am coming right oh i see you i saw you
up there
and
boom six so i just gotta end the game
on
that ass i forgot about that yeah if you
actually if it says six and you're not
there when six o'clock rolls around you
do still lose
so i just gotta the the trick is i gotta
have enough power to get to that so yeah
this is what i'm doing wrong is like i'm
not using the power well actually i am
using the power generation enough but
i'm flipping up the camera a lot more
which does drain a lot more battery than
it would okay
i just wanted to see that for the sake
of understanding where i was previously
i love this thumbnail wait
i i forgot about this hang on
i i forgot that i had a lot of fun doing
the thumbnails for uh
anyway
that's strange oh hey it's me
help me hey look it's me
wait no you can't see me wait wait hold
on hold on a second let me get you oh
hey let me get you a good view of where
i am
anyway look at that hey it's you guys
hey what do you know you can't see me oh
that's not good
i don't have a back button anymore guys
i don't know what's going on
um what do we do
what do i do
guys i don't have a background what do i
do
help
okay
oh god it's like we're stuck in some
kind of warm oh whatever
i've done that before um so if you guys
hey guys
i'm gonna keep going on this just a
little bit longer but
i'm gonna make at least an attempt at
some of this stuff but
do remember
in space with markiplier part 2 comes
out on monday
12 p.m pacific there's a link in the
description that'll take you to the
premiere page where we can all watch it
together together together like a team
like friends do
what do you say so do click on that link
in the description and join me for the
premiere because all of us can watch it
together live set a reminder on there
you go to that page you set a reminder
you come back please do it now
now i'm still going to be here when you
get back and we're going to try all this
nonsense but please remember to set a
reminder so that you don't forget so
that you're in the middle of your class
and then you can run screaming out of
the hallway into the bathroom and watch
the premiere
please link in the description please do
it it's going to be so fun it's going to
be incredibly fun you are going to love
it you are going to love it i want to
see how many of you guys uh also
um
left them left them love
for uh
the matpat video
let's see let's see how we're doing here
32 000 likes
32 000 likes there's more than 32 000
people here right at this moment
please
go to the game theorists
and click the like button
on this video here i did and i'm pretty
cool don't you want to be cool like me
please
do do all these things because it does
help him and and i want him to know that
like i do appreciate
him making a video about this it is that
it's just an honor like
i don't
i just like you know i wouldn't expect
it so do give some love to that like
click the like button not here don't
worry about this like button give matpat
over at the game theorists
some love there click that like button
on the game theory video which is titled
the end of markiplier
go check that out
that would be cool
that'd be so cool and then set a
reminder because you will be oh so much
more cool you'll be so cool you'll be
cool like me look how cool i am
i'm markiplier the definition of cool
yeah also the mods are linking that
video in the comments in the chat right
there so please give some love
please
i love this there's up to 34 000 likes
but that's not enough you can come back
here right afterwards you'll go there
i'll be right here still please take the
time to do it now and then i don't know
then you can do whatever you want and
i'm gonna try to bash my head against
the wall with ultimate custom night and
then we can all enjoy
the surging circle of love that is
embracing the internet right at this
moment together wouldn't you like that
wouldn't you like that
please
please
please
okay anyway
let's see how many people actually went
oh
oh we're up to 35 000 now so 3 000 of
the 45 000 people here actually went
guys
is it so hard
i asked for so little
someone went through the trouble to make
a video about me
and the project that i made
i know that some of you probably already
liked it so whatever if you can do we're
up to 36 thousand likes on that i really
appreciate that share with a friend give
out all the love in the world make it a
very successful video all this stuff
and also be here for the premiere on
monday please
please be here for the premiere on
monday
noon pacific standard time part two is
going to be
it's gonna be so much fun it's gonna be
so much fun
so
much
fun
thank you to all the people that are
currently chatting once this stream is
over i'll be over on the part to uh chat
um
hanging out with you guys so
tell the title oh it's game theorist the
end of markiplier that's that's the name
the the the mods have been linking it in
the comments there and then chat yes but
please do be there
please
and then play the hell out of it you are
going to have so
so much fun with part two you're going
to have
so much fun
you're going to have so much fun i know
you will i know you will i know you will
i know
so anyway
thank you
i'm shaking and i'm here yeah i'm
looking at the comments in uh or the
chat in the part 2 premiere page and if
you haven't seen the trailer for part
two uh go see it because the amazing
people at burning tractor made this
incredible and haunting trailer
i mean i did the audio for it the audio
was assembled from a few different
pieces but like
it's beautiful
it's wonderful it's haunting it's so
creepy if you haven't checked out the
website my god have you not even checked
out the website the lore that you're
missing out on did you even know that
there was a website i bet you didn't
i bet you didn't
i bet you didn't i bet you didn't know
that there was a website there is
there is a website
and hey
there might just be some changes on
there okay
okay
okay
all right enough about that yeah there
was a website you must have missed it
okay but enough about that
i
i'm gonna go back into this
so
there's a few things that i need to do
uh to get to the point where
to get to the point where i need to be
to be able to beat this
is
it's interesting thank you for doing all
the things thank you for that really
appreciate
really really appreciate it
did you like the map happened to you did
you watch it you'll watch it after this
one definitely um but also
all the other things i said liking or
setting a reminder and liking the
premiere page and be there on monday
and uh
tell someone something nice
okay cool good
good
all right so what i'm gonna do
is i just want to
walk myself through everything that i
need to do because i need to get
familiar with the controls
if i was going to get this
i have to do a certain number of things
in a very specific order before anything
gets done so it's like when i pop it up
it was like
so you have the first things first put
the power generator on
so that seems to be oh it's also popping
this over to the right
you basically
get enough coins to be able to get the
death coin
you come over here i i could have sworn
that they put the camera on the middle
one and then the x on that one i don't
know
i don't know why
so every time i i pop this up i need to
turn the heater on which one's the
heater heater's three
silent ventilation doesn't make any
sense why would you do that
does it make any sense
silent ventilation doesn't do anything
because the temperature just keeps going
up anyway
so what is the point what is the point
of that
i don't understand
what can i do for you what can i do for
you
so
deathcoin come here hit the death coin
on this one
and then
man this is just so much to think about
oh i didn't even remember to do this
which is very important because you need
to keep people i think what you probably
need to do is keep people a little i
think i saw them put it here
this one set up that one
snares are not effective
right
so then once you did that
basically once you get the death coin
and put that there you park this here
the music box i forgot about that five
is the global music box
i want to see something real quick
um so let's say i no not you i let's say
i have the marionette right
i need to see
how the global music box affects
this
so let's say for example i'm opening
this up i'm going here music box is
draining five
it rewinds it
what
fascinating
i didn't know that it rewound it i
thought it was just preventative but no
that's
that's incredible
i see okay i see okay
all right so that's one
let me see about toy freddy
toy freddy is right here
uh let me just go ahead and do 20
because i want to see what's going on
here
so this this put that there you there
was there something to do like
so
like wouldn't that
okay so it's changed
so why is this okay
to never look at again
i'm so curiou why is this okay to never
look at that
so it's
but otherwise i would be on a different
camera i would be over here or no i
would be over here
[Music]
[Music]
there's a random chance he will kill you
no matter what
so
what you're saying is
that is the rng you you are relying
entirely on that as an rng mechanic to
be able to get that
because
you just hope that he doesn't get you
huh
oh he can only kill you between point
zero and point five intervals on the
camera
are you kidding me
what
you're joking
how did people discover that
how
how would you know that
i don't know what animatronic is
weird
that's
just bizarre
there's no way
that's so strange
yeah i know the death coin can be used
on toy freddy but i'm imagining that
you're gonna use the death coin on
another one
because you want it on funtime
foxy because of reasons
right
strange
there's no way that i would be able to
time that to the millisecond you've got
to be joking is that serious is that
actually this the the strategy is that
actually the strategy
is it
there's no way there's got to be a
better option
freddy's harder to manage than foxy you
know what you might be right about that
you you might be because all
no actually
i don't know if that's correct am i
lagging by the way
am i am i lagging
hello
have i been lagging this whole time when
i'm a camera up when i'm camera uppy
have i been lagging this whole time
no i'm good
okay i better be
i better be okay cool good good to know
okay so he
yeah i don't know because isn't the
whole thing that you cannot get away
from this screen
i'm just so curious because because if i
recall
wasn't the whole idea
actually i can test this
i can test this
let's say we have
um
circus baby right
circus baby
apparently
if
you
have
the camera open
on two
no matter what
you have
no chance of dying right
isn't that the idea
isn't that the idea
number one crate is the strategy i don't
know what that means
i don't know what that means
i don't know what that means
also remember part two link description
definitely check it where are they
don't they appear by now
isn't that a thing i thought 45 seconds
in you would die
isn't that the idea
am i
crazy i could have sworn
right oh wet floor sign that's also
right
why aren't they supposed to be here
this is maybe supposed to be here
is the baby's supposed to be here
like crazy
either one three or five interesting
well it wasn't one
i guess this just must be an rng thing
but i want to see if i die
from having this open you know what i
mean because if i don't die
then that means that
i have to
camera stalling tutorial i'm sure i
could i do want to figure out some
things out for myself that's part of the
fun right isn't that part of the fun or
is it only winning the fun thing
fine
so like there's there's concessions that
you have to make for all of these that's
the problem like you you get half dozen
one six to the other and you have to go
one way or another uh to compromise
right
so in this factor if this is the way to
beat those things then you would have to
keep the camera on camera too
now the counterpoint to that
the counterpoint to that would be the
idea that you
buy the plushies which if you only
really need to buy a plushy buy one you
know what i mean
it's not necessarily
that hard
to get coins
you know what me mean
right
am i cr they're not there why are they
not there
like if you're always closing these
things and things are slamming into the
doors left and right all the time
you're getting a lot of coins right
plus couldn't you make the argument that
your your risk is clicking this thing me
bird likes you
because
because then the most valuable thing
here is the ten coins
because at that point
you
have almost what you need
i think
crazy
i'm crazy
i don't know where they are at the
moment they're supposed to be here
it's weird
it doesn't make any sense i mean it
makes sense but also it doesn't make
sense
doesn't make sense i should have
activated all of them
there you are okay so theoretically i
have not bought this but i'm keeping
camera two up
why i don't know
but apparently i will not die
if this camera stays there
right
camera's stalling
right
i don't die
i'm not dead yet
i'm not dead
and theoretically i would be going back
and forth between the music box and all
this stuff
i'm not dead
so okay
if you didn't do that
if you did not do that
you would need to get at least 30 coins
by the first hour of the game
which is a tall order
it is it's tall order
but the question is what is less rng
dependent
because i'm fast i'm faced
but you don't want to be too long on the
other menu because that is also a
problem
a lot of tricks
linky description
part two of in space with markiplier if
you haven't seen part one again or yet
do it
do it do it do it
what did amy amy texted me an hour ago
that this was my funniest bit in years
what did i do exactly one hour ago and
how do i recreate that
how do i replay what i just what did i
do an hour ago guys help what did i what
did i do an hour ago
amy thought i was funny
what did i do
help me
help me what did i do an hour ago
what did i say what did i do
what did i do
oh the doco thing
all right okay good good good
good okay all right
that's good to know that's good to know
i see okay all right good good good i'm
kind of curious i love you hang on one
second
uh
oh man i tried youtube shorts a little
bit ago i'm not i'm not sure
what schwarz is all about i mean i don't
mind youtube shorts like youtube shorts
cool and all but i
i don't really use it too much
i'm not gonna lie but
at the same time i just like
kind of i just i just wish it had its
own tab on youtube like youtube shorts
having its own tab because i just don't
like them cluttering up my videos
because i i work very hard on the
thumbnails to my videos and i make sure
that they're very meticulously designed
and if they're not meticulously designed
then i'm kind of pissed off
but at the same time it's you know it's
whatever ish whatever it's fine all
right what was i looking up
completely forgot
what did they just what was it gonna
look up what was i gonna do
what was i gonna do
what the f
what was i about i was going to look up
something
and i've completely forgotten what it
was because i was so excited i thought
that amy thought i was funny
yeah exactly i don't even mind i really
literally do not mind if um
if you know they don't if shorts didn't
show up in sub boxes i would actually be
fine with that because at least it's
predictable because the idea
is that if you're swiping through the
shorts tab which is fun you know
admittedly it's mostly just tick tock
content that's ripped and put there but
if you're swiping through it's
algorithmically based and fast and you
never would need to go to a subfeed
because it will learn what you like
creeps into your brain and all that
stuff so i'm fine if it doesn't go to
sub boxes it would just be nice to know
it's more consistent or something like
that i have no idea just just like some
transparency on how it works in the
first place what was i going to do
no it wasn't about the it wasn't about
the amy thing it was um
mark simp for amy confirmed i was
confirmed a long time ago my pal that
was confirmed long ago
um
[Music]
i've completely forgotten
help help me
oh
okay
yeah i was gonna um
freak
freak
i've completely forgotten
[Music]
oh man adhd moment yeah no uh i mean
yeah probably but
no yes no yes
no
yes could be actually i was switching
medications recently uh which is what
that whole cvs thing on twitter was
about um
god
oh
oh
i was gonna do 50 20 mode that's not
what i was going to do this it's it's
camera stalling
no what's the [ __ ] no i already i
already get what that is i just did it
no oh god
right
yeah uh there was a i had a problem with
cvs for a long time
hold on i'm trying to remember
it's a camera guy for the is okay oh i
remember what i was gonna look up it was
if camera stalling only worked on one
of the camera things if it only worked
on that
thing
so that if if there was another way that
camera stalling could work it would work
somewhere else okay
got it i'm fine
everything's good
it's all good okay
don't forget power-ups yeah i forgot
about the power-ups but at the same time
i don't want to use them right now until
i was trying to do anything actually
officially
yeah
adhd defeated i did it guys if i did
adhd how am i feeling i'm fine i was at
the hospital recently also the cvs thing
had nothing to do with me going to the
hospital i know that was like a
coincidence because i tweeted that
literally earlier in the day
that i then went to the hospital
not related in any way shape or form so
i'm not saying in any way that cvs sent
me to the hospital that's legally i'm
trying to cover my ass here that's not
what i'm saying i did the adhd
yeah
the cvs thing was i i was switching
medications right and this is not
something that i wanted to like publicly
tweet about because it's not a public
matter right it's not a thing but the
problem was right i was switching from i
i've been taking adderall for like 10
years and i'm not condoning any of this
this me only me i'm not a doctor ask
your own damn doctor about this [ __ ] but
i have been taking adderall for like 10
years and there's this new medication
called the stars that came out that i
wanted to try and the problem with a new
medication is that
trying to get your goddamn pharmacy or
insurance to even understand that there
is something out there let alone pay for
it is a [ __ ] nightmare
i spent literally and when i said on
that tweet that i've been trying to get
an answer for months that is not a lie
that was not a lie in any way shape or
form right i got my first prescription
in september
of last
year literally
september of last year is when i first
got this prescription for this new
medication right
and i would call up again and again and
again i would call cvs being like have
you ordered the medication and they're
like i don't know what this is i've
never heard of this medication from like
that's cause new can you order it and
they're like oh we'll try to order it
and then the next day they would call
like it didn't show up and i'd be like
why didn't it show up and then be like i
don't know why it didn't show up our
supplier just didn't buy it how about
you try a different medication i'm like
how about you try the one that my doctor
wrote a goddamn prescription for
how about you do that and then literally
i got so busy with uh doing in space all
the all the post-production stuff that i
actually i didn't get an answer for so
long that that prescription expired
right so i had to circle back around
get a new prescription
go back to cvs and i thought i thought
that it was like this was this was now a
month ago at this point i thought that
in the interim it's it must not be a new
medication anymore it must not be people
must have heard of this mythical esteros
and then people could probably have an
idea of where to get it and so i go to
the cvs to get this goddamn prescription
and they still tell me that it doesn't
exist
and i'm like they they give me this
thing we're like whoa we ordered it but
uh you know your insurance won't cover
it or you know the it might be out of
stock at the manufacturer you know what
they [ __ ] weren't
because i called the manufacturer and i
said why is cvs not getting this goddamn
thing filled and even they were like we
don't know why they wouldn't there's
been people at cvs who have gotten this
before and i'm like what do you mean
what do you mean that people have gotten
it why am i the bad guy here
and the craziest thing the craziest
thing is that when i finally made that
tweet when i finally made that tweet was
the only time that someone actually
tried to answer my question
but even during that call
i called them and i was like can you
tell me what's going on no
can you
why is the supplier not buying it i
don't know
can you talk to the supplier no
and so what they did is they called
the the pharmacy that i got it at to
finally be like why is this not
happening
and what it turns out is there was
another cvs
20 minutes down the road
that had it
and yet this cvs they're all cvs
didn't [ __ ] know that because they
didn't type in their system
where is this thing
and i was like god
it was 20 minutes down the road the
whole time
and you didn't even tell me
so all i did was have the prescription
transferred
and a day later boom i had it but it's
like it never would have happened if
someone just gave me a goddamn straight
answer
anyway
that's my little rant
about that
i am now done
about that
that
oh
i forgot how angry i was right because
the problem was i was angry and then i
went to the hospital so
i got like things shifted real quick
right things took a turn
for the difference
so so is the met any better for you uh
honestly it's too early to tell
because i started a few days ago so
there's like a transitionary period and
also like i'm not i'm not gonna give any
recommendations for stuff like that uh
so far so good i haven't exploded i will
i will say that i'm sleeping better
that's what i'll say i don't i can't
speak to anything because i haven't i
haven't tried it long enough but you
know so honestly oh this might not have
been worth it but so far so good i don't
know it's like placebo effect where i
have to love it you know what i mean
after all the trouble that i've been
through it's like i must i must but
anyway so but like i said it's not
something that i wanted to like talk
about publicly because
it's it's it's not your problem but then
it's the only way that it can work i
haven't yelled at a corporation in a
while you know
i've not last one was del monte or
actually
takis was dead to me
so you know having a good old fight with
the corporation is always
always a fun endeavor you know always
fun
anyway
i'm i'm
good i'm good guys
i'm good i'm good yeah any any type of
thing about like prescription stuff
that's a conversation between you and
your doctor that's a conversation that
for medical professionals to take care
of which oddly enough you know what it's
not like pharmacists aren't medical
professionals but my doctor wrote the
prescription why should an insurance
company even have any say in what
i'm not going to get into it i'm not
going to get into it
not going to get into it
okay all right i'm here for five nights
at freddy's okay i'm here to have a good
time i'm here to tell you about in space
with markiplier part two which is coming
out monday that's gonna be a real fun
time link in description set a reminder
[Music]
anyway it's all good now
it's all good now i have my
i'm good
it's all good
okay so what was i doing i've completely
forgotten what i was doing this game
i've completely forgotten
what am i doing i'll test out okay
camera right if the camera stalling
works on different things so what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna look up uh you
said that dj sturf had a good
uh camera stalling
thing
right okay let me look at this camera
stalling
uh
one second
boy hey what's up everyone dj sturf here
i'm going to start the night over here
let's turn on dd repel my last dd repel
lovely
and i have five nights at freddy's right
here in the foreground what why just the
first one
and i'm not going to do anything too
crazy here but i'm just going to move
over to cam 2. i'm just going to leave
it there let's drag this down a little
bit
yeah i collected a fazz coin in the
background
come on freddy come on freddy i freddie
at 20 everyone else at zero you are you
here freddy
yeah keep running freddy keep running
keep running
yeah
one more one more
oh no my right door is open oh no but i
have my camera on 4b is he still going
to jump scare me
a lot of people on the streams that i
did for five nights at freddy's one were
like oh man well you gotta you gotta
close that right door otherwise you're
gonna get jump scared but i have the
camera on cam 4b
this is called cam stalling this has
been around since the first five nights
at freddy's game there has to be a check
in there that says if your camera's
matching what this animatronic's on
don't let them jump scare you they can
advance but they're not going to jump
scare you if your camera's stuck on this
one now if i had my right door open now
and i moved off to any other camera if i
wanted to go to pirate code for some
reason which you really never have to
check you just have to do a frequent cam
check in five nights at freddy's one so
phone guy was
wrong on that dynamic in in some way
but
if i moved it off the camera right now i
would get jump scared by freddie or i
would have freddie come in the room and
then at a random time he would jump
scare me that's how that dynamic wait
hold on
hold the phone
you didn't actually need to check on
foxy
in five nights at freddy's one
what
what
you only needed to open the camera
what
oh
oh
right
you could eat
oh
so
so all of that time i was clicking
around cameras
i didn't need to do that
oh well i did hard mode so i'm better ha
take that dj
nerd
it goes in five nights at freddy's one
but basically you want to check bonnie
from time to time
uh because like very frequently because
you can't really hear bonnie in five
nights at freddy's one as fitting that
we have nightmare bonnie in the
background here and ultimate custom
night
and also whenever you see
cam 4b there's also some priority and
images going on as well and chica takes
priority over freddy meaning if they're
in the same spot there's not a graphic
that shows both of them it's just going
to show one of them and it's always
going to be chica so if they're both
there you're going to see chica and when
you see chica you're like okay well now
i got to check the right side to see if
chica moved toward the door or if chica
has moved away okay
so cam 4b is basically all you need for
five nights at freddy's one and i hope
that helps someone out because 420 mode
is really easy and almost always
replicable with a very high power
percentage remaining
i have to reinstall it to see what this
means in the meantime
part two
in space link
description
set a reminder
i'll be there after this stream just
kinda just gotta look something up you
know just gotta
just gotta look something up
let's go really think about something
okay just gotta
just gotta think about some stuff you
know just gotta
uh
where's this game there's this game
just gotta think about some stuff and
things
you know what i mean
just got to think about something
oh [ __ ] i forgot
well anyways i guess
i don't know whatever
god i don't do i really want to play
through all of five nights at freddy's
to try to test dumb theory
ah
welcome to five nights at freddy's one
we've re-revisited
that's what this god but you know what i
i guess it's for
specifically
the other thing where can i mute this
goddamn call
i'm back baby
oh my god you can't mute it oh i can eat
it [ __ ] it
baby i'm back come on roll
i'm back baby
[Music]
five nights at freddy's won the
revisiting use the skip short cd what
what cd plus
what what do you mean c hold c d
what
[Applause]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and i've been through some [ __ ]
but now baby i'm back alright so i made
this
[Music]
[Music]
dopamine is rushing through my little
brain
[Music]
here
[Music]
baby come back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give me
[Music]
have i finally grown taller
this always seems smaller
i'm the biggest
[Music]
dopamine is rushing through my little
brain
hello
[Music]
baby out of control come back
[Music]
all right that's enough i just needed a
mood boost i needed to get my mood up
because um i just had the most
devastating news that you can skip
nights in five nights at freddy's
oh anyway so we just oh it was playing
bam baby i'm back i'm on a roll
no that that's a great one um
can i just say
huge
immense incredible thank you to shmoyoho
accent on the yo
where's the whole i can't remember
they
they
they just
did such an incredible job
making the music for
space
and like i can't wait for you to see
what they have in store in part two part
two is gonna be so much fun but give
them all the love in the world
for
contributing so much to it they've done
so much for me and my channel and the
show and everything you know like in
heist yancy's song they made that they
made that it's
oh it's just like there's so many
talented people on on youtube and i'm so
lucky that people are gonna be able to
or be willing to help me out on this so
just oh yeah yeah i'm so good at this
bam oh
god damn i'm good
god damn
yeah they made all the music well not
all the music some of it obviously is
this music from uh stock music sites but
ah man i wish i could say more they're
just like they're so talented they're so
goddamn talented
yeah yeah yeah i am the best
oh i forgot the game just quits is this
supposed to happen whatever
that's why i'm the king that's why i got
the crown
sixth night all right this one's gonna
be tough guys i don't know a little
goddamn
yeah no they they just made some
incredible i oh can i okay before i do
this i i do want to pull up another one
of their songs that i just like is
like they've made a bunch of songs for
my channel just like remixes and stuff
but also at the
it's just like they're also incredibly
talented professional musicians
like
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
rises
[Music]
anyway just like
number one
bangers oops all bangers but number two
just like oh man they're just so
talented they deserve so much more than
the algorithm will get them and if
that's up to us giving them the love
they deserve we're gonna do that so send
them all the love of the world i don't
care tweet at them like their videos
watch their stuff incredibly talented
just like stupidly talented okay but
anyway
what we're gonna look at now is if this
is true about this nonsense here
about this
because i always had this thought and i
knew that there was something about how
if you didn't do something the
animatronics wouldn't do anything
because they had to wait for a change to
happen i did not know that extended that
there was some kind of permanence in
where the camera was positioned
in
like the the when it's down because i
know that when it's up it can do that
thing where it goes static and things
can change but the the thing about it is
like i didn't think that extended any
farther than it actually was
also how can you see if bonnie's there
that's the other question that i have
so if you keep this here right that's
the idea
i don't know
maybe you still gotta check these
so he's there
i guess you can always see
[Music]
see there yeah he's there will he really
will he really not
she's there
oh
i forgot about foxy
right
i forgot about that
so so is the thing where you just need
to flip up but that's that's crazy
freddy doesn't
attack
i always thought
it was a thing where you had to close
that door before putting up the camera
that was
the strategy
that was it
oh i know i know about the 87 thing i
guys i did this many years ago
i know
this wasn't even there at first i know
this so well when i first played this
when this first came out if you did this
it wouldn't do anything
scott
added this in
after the fact
i know that
that's how well i know this thing
that wasn't there originally
i am aware of that
bam
crown
shush
silence peasants
anyway back to ultimate custom night
oh yeah thank you motz for linking shmo
yoho if you haven't listened to shimo
yoho they're awesome
all right
so
with that i didn't even finish that
video i was watching that video trying
to learn more about the camera stuff i
just got so sidetracked
all right hold on because this is a 15
minute video i want to see what the rest
of this is about
and by high power i'm talking you know
anything at seven percent plus
uh on on any sort of run
okay
there's also a little trick here where
um
you kind of gotta
time it out like one two one two one two
and you get a drag
but i just kept the camera on 4b the
entire time and freddy didn't leave at
all so that's five nights at freddy's
one
and um
yay we got notice of termination
yay okay
that's five nights at freddy's one
cam stalling has been around since five
nights at freddy's one the dynamic is
still here here the plush animatronics
the controversy is is so real but it's
not a glitch this is something that has
to be in the click team action grid as
an actual check like if you're on this
camera don't let this animatronic jump
scare you there are only five that this
applies to but they apply to all the
plush animatronics plus two more and i
will show you the other two as well and
i hope that this can help you with your
strategies because you can use this in
other nights as well so if you have
lefty for example if lefty's at 20 it
doesn't matter if you can it doesn't
matter
you can just put the camera on cam 3 if
no one else is a camera hog
like funtime foxy where you actually got
to move off the camera
so there are gameplay dynamics where you
can use
the uh
you can use the
uh
whatever the readme the guide or
whatever for all those but we've also
seen that scott left off a few of those
dynamics initially like for chica
because chica was also soothed by a
music global music box being played but
it also doesn't mention that it's at the
15 30 45 one minute or whatever if
you're ai 20. interestingly too i have
23 seconds right now that i can move off
the camera but if i if i'm not back on
cam 2 by 4 minutes five seconds which is
20 seconds after the hour here one three
and five uh at ai20 i would get jump
scared so now i gotta stick on this
camera because it's almost interesting
so there's a 20 second window when a new
animatronic appears here that you can go
off of it but you have to be back for
the camera stalling to still apply it's
405
and it's really strict you'll get
jumpscared at 405.0 if you're not on cam
2 or if you haven't bought the plushie
so there are alternative ways of of
reaching a solution to getting rid of
this animatronic but one of them is
definitely programmed in as cam stalling
so
let me show you the other two and i'll
finish i'll just finish tonight but
you've seen this as an example and um
yeah this this is the prime example of
what
people have called glitches
or
exploits or whatever but it's something
that has to be programmed in the action
grid to actually register so that's why
i say this has been around since five
minutes afraid is one and uh
that's it so let's go to the other two
examples
um
and here we go
uh first one's rockstar chica
and i don't have a dd repel so i'm
hoping that this
dd isn't calling someone but this this
will be like a one minute demo or so so
um i'm just gonna i'm gonna go over to
cam one and you can see rockstar chica
advance and let's move the sign over to
the right side so that rockstar chica
can attack because if you had it on the
left side then that would block rockstar
chica anyway
so we're just gonna wait a little bit
here
you can keep it hot or cold i mean it
doesn't matter
just for this isolated example i wish i
had more dd repels at this point
yeah there's rockstar chica oh no the
door's open though why isn't she
attacking
because rockstar chica can be cam
stalled and if you let the ventilation
go out all bets are off
you just want to keep ventilated and all
that
um yeah
if i move off the camera right now
rockstar cheek is going to jump scare me
so let's actually do that all right i'm
going to move to cam seven ready set
jump scare warning
all right instant i may not absolutely
instant
because rockstar chica can be cam
stalled it prevents rockstar chica from
coming in your room
and that's it however as a contrast
let's look at freddy because freddy
cannot be cam stalled
and if you're looking at freddy
we're just gonna watch the the frames
advance all right so
i'm gonna keep it on cam one and freddy
either advances
uh at a two or three second starting
point usually here so
there he goes at ten he might have
actually started at four this time it's
one of the first seconds of the night
but here we go
he's just going to keep advancing we're
going to see
freddie and freddie since the door is
open
the only thing you have to do is shut
the left door to get rid of freddie and
you just do that before a camera check
and you're good but here freddie's going
to jump scare us
just in either 38 or 39 seconds in so
jump scare warning
oh 37 okay
even quicker this time
all right
hmm
so
the thing that i ask myself
about this
is
what is the intended behavior
right
so it's not a technological limitation
that one does something versus the other
right
one
one is something where
if i had to guess given that there is a
distinction and this happens to other
characters
there is a reactionary component to it
something where
no
that doesn't make any sense either
this has always been my problem
with
this methodology
of
playing
is
to me
much like what i just discovered about
five nights at freddy's one
if
if
let's say for example and i'm not i'm
not trying to discredit anyone else's
accomplishments that's not what i'm
saying this is all my personal opinion
about this
is if i had known
about this trick with keeping
five nights at or keeping freddy fazbear
on the camera and that would eliminate
him as a threat
i don't know if i could say to myself
that i actually beat him
that's me that's me that's my thing
and this is my exact same mentality
of why i chose to do 55
mode
versus what i was seeing
was the outcome of
you know people being 50 20. and again i
am not discrediting anything that anyone
has done it is not like it does not take
skill to do these things to be able to
get that but it's skill
and a whole lot
it's it's not exploiting i don't want to
say it's explaining like he's right it's
not exploitation it's
it's
it's lessening the mechanics that i
believe were intended to make it
easier
and i have a
i personally have an issue with making
things easier in considering it beaten
you know what i mean
then again there's a whole there's a
whole argument to be said but
if i had known
in five nights at freddy's 1 that you
could do that trick
i don't think i would have done it
i really don't
because i liked
how hard it was i liked how much nuance
it took i liked the fact that i thought
me going over to foxy on the camera had
an impact and that i needed to do it it
made it harder than it needed to be but
at the moment no one knew any better so
it was exactly as hard as it needed to
be
and when it comes down to mechanics like
this
and the camera stalling i think for this
one with ultimate custom knight it is a
necessity
i'm not saying that it could not be
beaten
without these mechanics because to be
perfectly honest
i kind of believe that you could
if someone tried hard enough and
actually did the mechanics represented
to them i wonder if anyone has done a
tool assisted like 50 20 mode where you
could see someone doing this
what what it is and what it represents
is something that is like a ultimate
challenge in terms of like my skill and
at the time i did not believe that i had
it i actually it's true even now i don't
is i have enough time to be able to do
50 20 mode in the way that it could be
i don't think it's impossible because
there are certain things that you can
definitely do and i i do believe that
having mechanics of this is is
definitely good and
whatever it's like a fine line of
wherever you decide to draw it
it's my masochist is showing hey listen
i like a challenge i do and i applaud
the effort of everyone here that is
doing this to the difficulty that it is
i'm not taking away anything from that
but my personal satisfaction in beating
these things has always been overcoming
like something that i thought would have
been literally impossible
anyway i'll leave it at that i'll leave
it to that my only thing that i could
say is like because i don't know enough
about 50 20 mood to even say that i
could beat it in any sort of way i'm not
saying that i could i definitely haven't
put enough time into looking into the
mechanics and i'm not trying to
criticize anything that they're saying
personally speaking
though i draw the line
if if the example is five nights at
freddy's one
and you
[Music]
hold
freddy at that camera
to beat the game
you did not beat 420 mode
that is where i draw the line i have
every right to speak about that one i
have no right at all to speak about the
ultimate custom knight because i have
not beaten it i will say that that is
where i leave it and that's what i say
so do i decree it
anyway
now back to me failing
now back to me failing
completely
all right
hold on a second here
all right
so doth do i decree it
all right i had to take care of a little
spam thank you very much
all right
now back to this
where am i
here i am
excellent
all right so
the other thing that i want to test out
is how many coins
[Music]
how many coins
you get from the doors because i gotta
figure out what the actual economy is
to this
because there is like these guys appear
at the doors right no matter what they
appear at the doors is there anything
that
i just had a thought
hang on i have to test it what happens
when the heat gets up
have i ever thought about what happens
when the heat goes
up like what is the physical effect
that occurs
when it gets too hot
so i have the heater on right now so i'm
literally boiling myself alive
it gets hot
does anything else happen
is there only is it only a situation
where certain animatronics are affected
by
the heat
what occurs what happens not a whole lot
but there are certain uh animatronics
that
are affected by it
heat causes him to appear faster okay
how much faster
that's another question
they don't like the spice i get that i
understand that
i understand that intensely okay so
you're there
so let's turn the heater on or peter on
is that faster
it
is that faster
might be
it's hard to say
it is it is faster okay it's definitely
faster
definitely
definitely faster
but a little bit interesting
okay
all right so that's another
that that's another interesting thing is
there any other character that's
affected by heat
one work of the office is 100 degrees or
more ah that's the issue
so if the office heats up
she will appear in both hallways at the
same time
interesting and you can't close the
doors
is that was that what i read like you
cannot close the doors
how do you know when she appears
ah there she is so
she'll kill me
if i
open the doors or is it going to happen
anyway
it happens anyway
sorry jumpsuit
ah
okay
hello
please can i
please i need to
please
please i must
uh
there we go okay
so that's interesting that is
interesting
oh hello
someone here i missed it
i have no idea is someone here
someone by the name of dj
who i see nothing
a myth
a shadow in the night
gone
forever oh there you are okay okay i see
i see i see
cool
uh
interesting
fascinating
fascinating
it's me hello what a
handsome man
much more handsome than that darko
fellow what a nerd
i don't know i always love going on to
mad past live streams and just being the
biggest [ __ ] possible that's what i
usually do when i'm on other people's
content in the first place i just try to
be as big a dick as possible
hello
all right i look dj i'm i'm doing
ultimate costume night
you proud of me
look
i'm learning
all right let me see so
the interesting thing about heat
is i wonder
because the
i mean obviously heat is bad but is heat
really only dictated by this
as a problem i think there's another one
that um
the pink
[ __ ] the pink [ __ ] uh the pink
[ __ ]
causes to spawn right
right
there's something that does that
there's something wait why don't you
have anything oh oops have you guys not
seen anything
oops
uh
now look i'm learning i'm a good
youtuber i'm a good streamer
i'm a great streamer i know exactly what
i'm doing
go see my show in space part two is very
good it's very good actually it's
extremely good you're gonna love it
link's in the description
all right yeah
so yeah i think there's another one that
that brings in
don't let it linger
yeah because there's some there's some
things that i
unless i'm misunderstanding something
there's some things about this that i
i'm not
i'm doubtful of of my like looking at
this in like terms of the fastest way to
beat this
uh in a way that i
would want to beat it
ballora gives you nightmares why
what's wrong with balora
i'm so curious
i'm gonna do a thing here um i just
wanna i just wanna test something out
here
i'm gonna die immediately because i'm
gonna forget someone's mechanic even if
they're like number one i'm not gonna be
able to do it you get that there you get
that there you have five for the global
music box to be able to do that you set
that there
oh god what do i do i've completely
forgotten
um so foxy
is technically there and if you look
that's good close this
there's so many people
there's so many animatronics
that
i'm probably forgetting some
you want the death coin for fun time
because that's gonna happen anyway
there's a show
there
oh
and then you have right you still have
all of this nonsense you don't need the
show here
whatever
i'm not doing this the way it should be
done even if i wanted to do it the right
way you're there
you
just flash golden freddy there for a
second you know how it'd be right
that one
interesting
and i'm gonna probably how may i be of
service to you i'm gonna die
definitely
okay i guess you forgot about me well i
wasn't about to i was about to get you
something
am i lagging
am i lagging horribly
probably not
oh yes i am
yes i am
fascinating because because this is what
i loved about like doing the
i do like this game i don't want anyone
to think that i don't i really actually
do
i think it's a fascinating
complex
ludicrously designed beast of a game
it is just stupid
how much
is here
there's just so
much going on so many layers and i wish
there were more secrets actually i
really do
um
and it's something that's like
thoroughly enjoyable to just ratchet up
the sheer difficulty and the number of
things that you got that
it it's like very
pleasing
to the brain you know and i mean it like
scratches a very particular extremely
complex itch
that i think is just fascinating it
doesn't apply to any other game that i
have seen in recent years or in past
years it reminds it's like a bullet hell
in a lot of ways which i enjoy i love
complex very tightly focused platformers
yeah yeah most of these secrets are just
voice lines i mean what else could they
really be i mean you could have like
some secrets hidden in here game
mechanics and stuff like that it
scratches an itch it scratches a very
specific itch and it's an issue that you
don't get a lot and i have not played a
lot of bullet hells recently but you
know it's kind of like
i like the concept of having all these
plates spinning up in the air and you're
juggling like a chain dozen chains saws
at the same time and you get like think
it's like a complexity of like patting
your head and rubbing your stomach and
trying to like i can't even do it
properly but because like doing all that
it's very very cool
very very cool
50 20 best time 18 seconds you know it
baby
you know it
but
i think
here's what i think
despite everything that i've just
learned
in this stream
i would not say with any sort of
confidence that i would be able to beat
it
at this time in in enough time that i
have for today i definitely
would not be able to beat this it is
too big of a task and i have not
dedicated enough time to it
however what i will say
is that
i swear
i swear
there is a
different way
to beat
50 20. and i'm sure it's already been
done that i'm sure it already has
but there's a different way
because even looking back at me playing
55
and seeing like yes i was very quick not
not as quick as i needed to be to be to
beat it more easily but i was very quick
and it was something that was super
super interesting to keep all of these
plates in and to like oh yeah every hour
on the or every hour on the hour every
hour on the hour and doing all those
things like it's very interesting i want
to come back to this if you haven't if
you haven't figured out i am out of time
for today i this this stream has gone on
way longer than i thought it would uh
but at the same time like if it's for
just about five hours now at the same
time i want to come back to this one
i really do
i want to come back to this one i want
to because one of my favorite things to
do is exactly what i've been doing is
like looking at each of these
individually and like
trying to
understand the nuances of it i know
that there is definitely going to be
some compromises that need to be done
that you have to find one or another
i'm curious about this
i am super
curious
about this
but it'll wait for another day so i want
to say this very very quickly before
anyone goes hey hold on hold on hold on
hey
listen when i come back
i'm going to part two of in space with
markiplier comes out on monday at noon
pacific there's a link in the
description i will be in the chat after
this
messing with you guys over there if you
want to keep going um but remember
i will get back to normal videos that
means a normal upload schedule of
completely normal videos
two weeks
after part two releases i know some of
you are like oh but it's been so long i
worked on this for two years right after
going through unisonis and then straight
out straight before that i was doing
heist i haven't taken a break since then
this is my break i've earned it however
there will be
a space behind the scenes live stream
that we will do the following sunday not
tomorrow sunday one week from sunday all
about the process of space because we i
want people to have a chance to watch it
i want people to have a chance to enjoy
it to tear through it really appreciate
it i mean [ __ ]
we put so much time and effort into it
you rabid animals stop ripping it apart
in two hours just in just pace
yourselves you need like one of those
doggy bowls that has the puzzles in it
because you just consumed too quickly if
you consume too quickly
tell a friend about it and spread the
word about it give all the love to the
people that were a part of the show
everyone who contributed go give them a
thank you for the delicious meal that
you just devoured and way too quickly
okay
understand
and also really truly just enjoy that
all of it you are going to love
part two you are going to love
part 2 it has everything you want i
promise you it has everything
so check it out
on monday i will be there and you will
be there live at the premiere so that we
can all enjoy it together
and with that being said matpat did
release a video about in space you
should go check that out and give it a
like if you didn't already and remember
in the link in the description right
down there
is the link to the part 2 premiere set a
reminder so that you will be reminded
when 12 p.m pacific standard time rolls
around on monday okay
i understood
all right
thank you
and as always i will see you when
monday 12
noon that's p.m pacific standard time i
don't want to see you at midnight on the
page it will be too early or too late
so i'll see you then just remember
monday
okay and with that i'm gonna go okay bye
guys farewell thank you so much for
joining the stream i will see you all
monday and check out the website while
you still can
while you still can
okay all right i'm gonna go now but i'm
gonna watch oh no i'm gonna go i'm gonna
watch you i'm gonna go